AFTERNOON EVERYONE.
I AM ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN
MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND PROUD TO REPRESENT
THE TWENTY SECOND.
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT I WANT TO
WELCOME ALL OF YOU. TO THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON
BIOTECHNOLOGY INFORMATIONAL
HEARING.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
JOINING US TODAY I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE DR BILL QUIRK FROM
THE EAST BAY.
HOW FOR JOINING US OUT WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS LIFE
I BELIEVE WILL BE TRICKLING IF
YOU HAVEN'T NOTICED SINCE THIS
IS THE BUSY SEASON?
HA IN THE LEGISLATURE SO WE HOPE
TO HAVE A FEW MORE MEMBERS --
BUT WE ARE WILL HAVE THIS IS
WELL ON ASSEMBLY TV I WANT TO
THANK --
INJURIES AND GOLLY MY
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR AS WELL AS
LAURA FITZGERALD OF MY STAFF FOR
HELPING ME --
COORDINATE AND ORGANIZE THE
HEARING TODAY I AM HONORED TO
CHAIR THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
BIOTECHNOLOGY OUR OVER ARCHING
GOAL WITH THIS COMMITTEE IS TO
ENSURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
UP TO DATE.
AND WELL INFORMED ABOUT THE
BIOTECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY FOCUSES ON THREE KEY
ASPECTS OF THE BIOTECH ECOSYSTEM
IN OUR STATE.
OUR RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IMPORTANT LEGAL AND REGULATORY
ISSUES IMPACTING THE INDUSTRY.
AND HOW THIS INDUSTRY IS
SUPPORTING AND SUPPORTED BY OUR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS.
TODAY'S HEARING IS VERY
APPROPRIATE THAT IN PROVIDING US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
REGENERATIVE MEDICINE.
ALSO KNOWN AS SERVE.
AS WELL AS FROM INDIVIDUALS AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE WORKED
WITH OR OBSERVED SARM --
IN THE TIME SINCE ITS INCEPTION
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF PRESENTERS
THAT WE PLAN HERE FROM TODAY AS
YOU CAN SEE IN THE AGENDA.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS OF
THE PRESENTERS AFTR EACH AGENDA
ITEM WE WILL ALSO I GIVE A
CHANCE FOR ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
ARE AT THE AT TOWARD THE END OF
OUR HEARING IN OUR GOAL IS TO
WRAP UP BY THREE PM --
IF AT ALL POSSIBLE.
SO A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
CALIFORNIA STEM CELL AGENCY WAS
CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR
WHEN 59% OF CALIFORNIA VOTERS
APPROVED PROPOSITION.
SEVENTY ONE THE CALIFORNIA STEM
CELL RESEARCH AND CURES
INITIATIVE.
THAT INITIATIVE AUTHORIZED THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR
STEM CELL RESEARCH IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHICH CREATED THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR REGENERATIVE
MEDICINE.
THE MEASURE IN DOUBTS ARE WITH
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN BHADRAK
ANY TO FIND CALIFORNIA STEM CELL
LABORATORIES IN A TRACK WORLD
CLASS RESEARCHERS.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
HELL TWO INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF PROP
SEVENTY ONE IN MARCH AND
OCTOBER.
OF TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE THE
FIRST FOCUSED ON OVERSIGHT WHILE
THE LATTER FOCUSED ON
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
THERE WAS ALSO A REPORT BY THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE WHICH MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR CHANGES IN
SERVICE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
AND INCREASED TRANSPARENCY AND
ITS ACTIVITIES SEVERAL OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE CODIFIED
WITH THE PASSAGE OF SB TEN SIXTY
FOUR BY SENATOR ALL QUIST.
IN.
TWENTY TEN SIR BEGAN ISSUING
GRANTS IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX
AND AS I UNDERSTAND IT'S
ANTICIPATED THAT IT WILL BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO FIND NEW PROJECTS
UNTIL SOMETIME IN.
TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN WE WILL
HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT AS THE
HEARING --
PROCEEDS AS THIS IS THE FIRST
HEARING OF THE LEGISLATURE ON
CERN IN SEVERAL YEARS IT WOULD
BE INFORMATIVE TO HEAR FROM
TODAY'S PRESENTERS ABOUT WHAT
SERVE HAS ACHIEVED ITS MISSION
AND WEST PLANS ARE. FOR THE
FUTURE AND BEFORE WE OPEN UP OUR
INITIAL PANEL I'D LIKE TO SEE IF
MY COLLEAGUE DR QUIRK --
HAS ANY INITIAL COMMENTS BOB
THANK YOU A SHARE MULLIN.
FOR HAVING THIS SELECT COMMITTEE
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
LEARNING A LOT TODAY THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT THANK YOUR DOCTOR
QUIRK SO WITH THAT LET'S GET TO
OUR FIRST PANEL WERE JOINED BY
DOCTOR MARIA MALIGN C. E. O. OF
SARM.
SENATOR OUR TOUR AS A FAMILIAR
FACE IN THIS BUILDING WHO IS THE
VICE CHAIR OF TERMS GOVERNING
BOARD AS WELL AS JOHN REED OF
THE ROMAN READ FOUNDATION FOR
SPINAL CORD.
RESEARCH WELCOME AND THANK YOU
ALL OF YOU FOR BEING HERE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MISTER
CHAIRMAN IT'S AN HONOR TO TO BE
HERE DOCTOR QUIRK IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU AGAIN AS WELL THANK YOU
MRS AYE GOLLY FOR YOUR HELP IN
PUTTING THIS IMPORTANT HEARING
TOGETHER.
OF OUR BOARD IS COMPOSED OF OUR
CHAIR DOCTOR JONATHAN THOMAS WHO
COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY.
AND TWENTY EIGHT BOARD MEMBERS A
TEN OF WHOM ARE PATIENT
ADVOCATES FOR VARIOUS DISEASES I
BEING ONE OF THEM IS A COLON
CANCER.
SURVIVOR REPRESENTING CANCER AS
EFFICACY ON THE ON THE BOARD.
OF THERE'S YOU'VE BEEN INDICATED
THE INITIATIVE WAS PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR BY 59% OF THE
VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ISSUED A ECONOMIC IMPACT
REPORT IN.
TWENTY TWELVE THAT FOUND THAT
THE ONE POINT SIX BILLION INSERM
GRANTS THAT HAD BEEN COMMITTED
AS OF JULY OF TWENTY TWELVE AND
THE ONE POINT THREE BILLION AND
PRIVATE GENERATED MATCHING
FARMS.
FROM DONORS AND OTHER
INSTITUTIONS A ALLOWED US TO
CREATE THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT FTA
EASE AND CALIFORNIA OR ABOUT.
FOUR THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO JOBS PER YEAR OVER
THIS NINE YEAR PERIOD.
AS A RESULT.
OF OUR EFFORTS IN THESE FUNDS
AND THESE AND THESE ARE MATCHING
FUNDS WE'VE PAID THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OVER TWO HUNDRED
EIGHT POINT SIX MILLION IN TAX
REVENUES [inaudible]
AND EIGHTY TWO POINT SIX MILLION
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT POINT EIGHT
MILLION TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND TAX REVENUES AS A
RESULT OF OUR ACTIVITIES.
AS WE KNOW WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE MY FAVORITE
AND THEY ARE.
TO THE BRIDGES PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES FOR INTERNSHIPS FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
STUDENTS AND WE HAVE HAD ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED NINE OF
THE STUDENTS COME THROUGH THAT
PROGRAM MANY OF WHOM ARE
DIVERSE.
MANY OF WHOM COULD NOT AFFORD TO
STAY IN SCHOOL BUT FOR THE
MINIMAL STIPEND THAT WE HAD
PROVIDED THEM.
AND ALSO TO WORK IN STEM CELL
LABS FOR THE SUMMER.
THAT WE OFFER THEM THAT'S
STIPEND ALSO OFFER THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY AND MANY OF THEM
HAVE MOVED ON TO OTHER ACADEMIC
ENDEAVORS AS A RESULT OF THEIR
EXPERIENCE.
AND HE'S LAPS AND THEN WE ALSO
STARTED IT WHICH I HELPED START
THE SPARK PROGRAM.
WHICH WAS HERE TOO PINPOINTING
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WITHIN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ALSO PAY THEM A VERY
SMALL INTERNSHIP AND SO FAR FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
THIS EXPERIENCE AND YOU WOULD BE
INSPIRED IN THRALL TO HEAR THESE
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
TALK LIKE PHD CANDIDATES IN
PRESENTING THEIR WORK THEY DID
OVER THE SUMMER AS WE JUST HEARD
A FEW WEEKS AGO OR LAST WEEK
RATHER UC DAVIS.
THESE ARE OUR FUTURE STEM CELLS
SCIENTISTS WHICH WE HAVE TO
NURTURE AND WE HAVE TO ENCOURAGE
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
A WE ALSO AND SENT YOU A VIDEO
THAT EACH MEMBER WILL RECEIVE OF
TWO OF OUR SPINAL CORD INJURY
PATIENTS IN WHAT'S CALLED THE
SCARIEST BIO THERAPEUTICS
CLINICAL TRIALS.
JACOB VIA FROM DANVILLE AND
CHRIS BOATSWAIN FOR BAKERSFIELD.
I YOU WILL DEFINITELY INSPIRED
TO KNOW THAT JAKE IS NOW CAL
POLLY.
ASSEMBLY SO BISPO STUDY
BIOMEDICAL ENGINEERING AND DID
RELEASE FOR ME ON HIS
WHEELCHAIR.
WHICH HE COULD NEVER DO THAT
RIGHT AFTER THE INJURY AND CHRIS
WAS THE FIRST PATIENT TREATED
WITH TEN MILLION CELLS STEM
CELLS.
AND HAS EXPERIENCED THE MOST
IMPROVEMENT VIDEO HE COULD NOW
LIFT WEIGHTS AND HE COULD NOW BE
MUCH MORE MOBILE THAN HE WAS
ESPECIALLY AFTER THE AFTER THE
ACCIDENT.
AND SO I THINK IT'S IT'S SO
IMPORTANT FOR US TO GET A SENSE
OF WHERE WHERE WERE MOVING
THAT'S WHY OUR CEO IS IS HERE
TODAY DOCTOR MARIA MILAN.
IS A PHYSICIAN SCIENTIST WHO HAS
DEVOTED HER LIFE TO DEVELOPING
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS FOR
CHILDREN ADULTS WITH
DEBILITATING LIFE THREATENING
CONDITIONS.
SHE RECEIVED HER UNDERGRADUATE
TO DO THAT ARE UP MEDICAL
DOCTORAL RESEARCH AT HARVARD
MEDICAL SCHOOL IN BOSTON.
AND AFTERS A TRANSPLANT SURGERY
FELLOWSHIP AT STANFORD SHE BEGAN
HER ACADEMIC CAREER WITH THE
BUSY VERY BUSY PEDIATRIC AND
ADULT A TRANSPLANT SURGERY.
PRACTICE IT WITHIN FIVE YEARS
SHE WAS A OF A APPOINTED AS AN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR AND DIRECTOR
OF THE PEDIATRIC ORGAN
TRANSPLANT PROGRAM.
CHOOSE PUBLISHED SIGNIFICANTLY
IN THE AREA AND THEN WENT ON TO
THE PRIVATE SECTOR WITH ONE OF
THE EARLIEST STEM CELL
ORGANIZATIONS WHICH WAS THE
FIRST STEM CELLS INK. TO ENTER
INTO AN FDA REGULATED CLINICAL
TRIAL WITH THE STEM CELL
TREATMENT.
IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWELVE SHE
REALLY LED THE EFFORT TO CREATE
WHAT WE CALL THE ALPHA.
CLINICS NETWORKS WHICH ARE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHICH IS NOW SUPPORTING OVER
FIFTY SIX CLINICAL TRIALS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IN JULY OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
ON THE BOARD APPOINTED HER IS
ARE.
PRESIDENT CEO AND FORMALLY
APPOINTED HER IN SEPTEMBER.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN DR MILA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
TORRANCE FOR YOUR KIND
INTRODUCTION MISTER SPEAKER.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY DOCTOR
QUIRK --
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO BE HERE
TODAY AND AN HONOR TO PRESENT AN
UPDATE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
REGENERATIVE MEDICINE.
AT CERTAINLY NEVER FORET THAT
WE WERE THIS AGENCY WAS FORMED
BY THE BY THE PASSAGE OF
PROPOSITION.
PROPOSITION SEVENTY ONE BY THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN OUR MISSION REMAINS TO
ACCELERATE STEM CELL AND
REGENERATIVE MEDICINE TO
PATIENTS WITH UNMET MEDICAL
NEEDS.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE PROGRESS
THAT WE'VE MADE TODAY IT
SOMETIMES?
QUITE AMAZING TO THINK THAT THE
HUMAN STEM CELL WAS FIRST
ISOLATED ONLY TWENTY YEARS AGO
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THIS
OPENED UP A WHOLE NEW FIELD.
BECAUSE THE STEM CELL HAD THE
UNLIMITED CAPACITY TO
PROLIFERATE AND TO GIVE RISE TO
EVERY CELL IN THE BODY.
THIS REALLY CAPTURED THE HUMAN
IMAGINATION AND PROMINENT
SCIENTISTS IN THE FIELD PROPOSED
THAT THIS COULD ELUCIDATE.
MECHANISMS AND HELP US SOLVE THE
TOUGHEST MEDICAL DISEASES THAT
THAT ARM ARE ARE DEVASTATING OUR
CHILDREN AND ADULTS.
AT THAT TIME IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT TO TWO THOUSAND THERE ARE
VERY FEW STEM CELL SCIENTISTS
ARE VERY FEW.
WHO COULD AFFORD TO PURSUE THIS
LINE OF RESEARCH BECAUSE THERE'S
SO IT JUST WAS NOT NOT ENOUGH
FUNDING FOR THIS AND IT WAS SUCH
A NEW FIELD?
BECAUSE OF THE VISION OF THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA PATIENT
ADVOCATES RESEARCHERS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS.
THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE WAS
FORMED IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR
AS YOU SAID BY THE PASSAGE OF
PROPOSITION.
SEVENTY ONE AND SINCE THEN
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN THE LEADER
IN THE FIELD AND REMAINS AT THE
HELM AT THE FOREFRONT.
OF WHAT'S NOW CONSIDERED OF
MEDICAL REVOLUTION CALLED
REGENERATIVE MEDICINE.
WITH OUR TEAM OF HIGHLY TRAINED
AND EXPERIENCED PROFESSIONALS.
STERN HAS DEVELOPED A WAY TO
PARTNER WITH THE BEST ACADEMIC
AND INDUSTRY PROJECTS TO FAST
TRACK THEM TO GET INTO
THERAPEUTICS BY GOING THROUGH
THE STAGES OF ARE BEING TESTED
IN CLINICAL TRIALS.
WITH OUR TIMELY AND EFFICIENT
FUNDING PROCESS EXPERT
REVIEWERS.
ADVISORY RESOURCES CRITICAL
STRATEGIC INFRASTRUCTURE AN IN
HOUSE EXPERTISE WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO FIND THE HIGHEST QUALITY
PROGRAMS AND ACCELERATE THE
PROGRESSION. TO TESTING A
POTENTIAL CURATIVE TREATMENTS
FOR PATIENTS WITH A BROAD RANGE
OF INDICATIONS FOR WHICH THERE
ARE NO TREATMENTS OR CURES. TO
DATE CERTAIN HAS FOUND THAT OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED PROJECTS THAT OVER
IT SEVENTY INSTITUTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IS THE LARGEST SINGLE FUNDER
IN THE WORLD OF CLINICAL
RESEARCH FOR STEM CELL AND
REGENERATIVE MEDICINE.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE
LAUNCHED A BOLD FIVE YEAR
STRATEGIC PLAN.
A PLAN WAS CREATED SO THAT WE
COULD DELIBERATELY AND
STRATEGICALLY CUT THE TIME AND
HALF THAT IT WOULD TAKE. TO GET
THE RESEARCH TO GO THROUGH THE
STAGES TO GET INTO THE CLINICS
IF IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S MEANT
TO GO TO THE CLINICS.
AND WE ALSO STRATEGICALLY
CREATED A WAY TO BRING IN THE
HIGHEST.
ATTENTION ALL PROJECTS AND TO
BUILD A WORLD CLASS PORTFOLIO OF
CLINICAL PROJECTS THAT WE HAD
MORE SHOTS ON GOAL TO SOLVE
THESE DEBILITATING --
DISEASES AND CONDITIONS FOR
WHICH THERE IS NO TREATMENT OR
CURE.
TODAY SIR ARM HAS FUNDED FORTY
NINE FDA REGULATED CLINICAL
TRIALS AND IS FUNDED THE
TREATMENT OF OVER NINE HUNDRED
PATIENTS IN THESE CLINICAL
TRIALS. FOR A BROAD RANGE OF
INDICATIONS INCLUDING FATAL
PEDIATRIC ORPHAN DISEASES
STROKE.
THE GUARDS DISEASE ALS SPINAL
CORD INJURY AS YOU HEARD ABOUT
HEART DISEASE.
CHEMOTHERAPY RESISTANT ADVANCED
CANCERS [inaudible]
DIABETES.
BLINDING EYE DISEASE.
SICKLE CELL DISEASE JUST TO NAME
A FEW.
IN THE NEXT FEW MOMENTS I JUST
LIKE THE HIGHLIGHT.
THE TYPES OF PROJECTS THAT
SERMONS PARTNERED.
THESE INNOVATIVE HIGH RISK HIGH
REWARD PROP PROGRAMS THAT.
SERRANO WAS UNIQUELY DESIGNED TO
ACCELERATE AND TO PARTNER WITH
IN ORDER TO INCREASE THE
PROBABILITY OF SUCCESS TO
GETTING TO PATIENTS.
THE FIRST EXAMPLE WE HAVE --
YOU OUT ME LATER ON A
REPRESENTATIVE --
FOR A PATIENT WHO IS ENROLLED IN
THIS TRIAL.
AND ONE OF THE TRIALS WHERE
FUNDING.
TRIALS AND THREE DIFFERENT FORMS
OF A GENETIC DISEASE CALLED
SEVERE COMBINED
IMMUNODEFICIENCY.
WHERE BABIES ARE BORN WITHOUT
FUNCTIONAL IMMUNE SYSTEM SO THE
COMMON COLD COULD RESULT IN
FATAL COMPLICATIONS?
THE PROGRAMS WHERE FUNDING ARE
USING THE BABY'S OWN STEM CELLS.
JEAN ENGINEERING THEM SO THEY
CAN CORRECT THE GENE DEFECT THAT
LEADS TO THE IMMUNE DEFICIENCY.
GIVING THEM BACK TO THE PATIENTS
WHERE THE STEM CELLS BECAUSE OF
THE REMARKABLE QUALITY HOME TO
THE BONE MARROW WHICH IS THEIR
USUAL HOME.
AND GIVE RISE TO TO THE ARM
FUNCTIONAL IMMUNE CELLS AND THE
BABY IS ESSENTIALLY CAN HOW
THESE REPLAYED IT THROUGHOUT
THEIR LIFE BECAUSE THE STEM
CELLS HAVE THE ABILITY. TO
CONTINUE TO PERSIST AND GIVE
RISE TO NEW SELF.
AS THE BABY GROWS.
YOU WILL HEAR FROM BABY RONNIE'S
FAMILY.
WHO IS AND BABY RONNIE WHAT WAS
ENROLLED IN A TRIAL AT UCSF --
FOR EXPLAINED SKIT.
AND IN OUR COVER OF OUR TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN ANNUAL AND BABY
RONNIE'S ON OUR TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN ANNUAL REPORT WHICH
YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU --
IN OUR TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
ANNUAL REPORT WE HAD A PICTURE
OF OF EP WHO IS NOW FIVE YEARS
OUT FROM.
HER TRANSPLANT WITH THE THE
SIMILAR APPROACH FOR HER FORM OF
SKID CALLED ABA SKID SHE'S CURED
SHE HAS A FULLY FUNCTIONAL
IMMUNE SYSTEM.
SHE IT GOES TO SCHOOL AND HIS
DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY MEDICATIONS
WHATSOEVER SOVIET HER PARENTS
ARE -- VERY
VERY --
VISIBLE ON THE CAN YOU.
AREA OF HOW IT HAS CHANGED OUR
LIVES NOW SHE THE MOTHER HER
MOTHER DOESN'T HAVE TO HOLD
THEIR BREATH ANY TIME EVEY
TOUCHES SOMETHING OR THEY CAN GO
OUT IN PUBLIC WITHOUT FEELING
LIKE -- OF
BEING USING A PUBLIC RESTROOM
MAY LEAD TO HERS HER DAUGHTER'S
DEMISE.
THIS PROJECT IS IN ITS PIVOTAL
PHASE MEANING THAT ONCE THIS
TRIAL IS COMPLETE THE DATA WILL
BE EVALUATED BY THE FDA.
AND DETERMINE WHETHER IT WILL GO
OUT FOR MARKETING APPROVAL AND
BE MADE MORE AVAILABLE --
TO ALL PATIENTS OUTSIDE OF A
CLINICAL TRIAL.
SO THE ENCOURAGING RESULTS WITH
SKIT.
PROVIDES A PROOF OF PRINCIPLE
FOR THIS INCREDIBLE PARADIGM
SHIFT IN THE FIELD.
CURATIVE ONE TIME TREATMENT.
USING THE PATIENT'S OWN STEM
CELLS.
THIS GIVES US TRUE HOPE. FOR THE
OTHER ESTIMATED TEN THOUSAND
HUMAN DISEASES THAT ARE DUE TO
SINGLE GENE MUTATIONS FOR WHICH
SUCH AN APPROACH COULD ALSO BE
USED. TO CORRECT THEM.
AND THE SECOND EXAMPLE I WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT A DIFFERENT
THERAPEUTIC APPROACH
[inaudible]
WHICH COMBINES.
SURGICAL ADVANCES WITH.
STEM CELLS GENE THERAPY.
WE FIND A DOCTOR TO BE MACKENZIE
AT UCSF SHE'S A PEDIATRIC
SURGEON AND A RESEARCHER.
WHO'S A DEVELOPED A TECHNIQUE
TREAT BABIES WHO HAVE ALFA
THALASSEMIA WHICH IS A FATAL
BLOOD CONDITION.
OFTEN THESE BABIES DON'T MAKE IT
TO FULL TERM THEY'RE LOST IN
EURO AND I A MISCARRIAGE.
SHE TREATS THE SPEED OF SAYS
WHILE STILL ON THE MOTHER'S WOMB
[inaudible]
WITH.
MATERNAL STEM CELL TRANSPLANT
THE BABIES BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL
HAVE THE MUSE SYSTEM TO ACCEPT
THE MOTHER STEM CELLS.
CAN ACCEPT THE STEM CELLS AND
GIVE RISE TO NORMAL BLOOD CELLS.
THE IDEA IS TO BRING THE BABIES
TO FULL TERM.
AND THE ULTIMATE.
GOAL IS TO HAVE THEM BE FULLY
CURED BUT SHOULD THEY REQUIRE
TRANSPLANT AFTER BIRTH NOW
THEY'RE TOLERANCE TO THE MOTHER
SO WHEN THEY GET THE TRANSPLANT
IF THEY NEEDED EVERY DOES AFTER
TRANSPLANT.
THEY'RE ABLE TO ACCEPT THE
CELLS.
THIS STORY ALONG WITH THE
PICTURE OF A VERY PINK AND CUTE
THREE WE CALLED WHO WAS THE
FIRST PATIENT ENROLLED IN THIS
TRIAL WAS FEATURED.
AND ON IN THE MAY TWENTY FIFTH
ISSUE OF THE NEW YORK TIMES.
AND WHAT THAT CHILD IS STILL ON
GOING BUT IT'S VERY ENCOURAGING.
MANY OF YOU HAVE HEARD --
THE EXCITEMENT AROUND
IMMUNOTHERAPY AND CARTY
THERAPIES.
AND AS YOU KNOW TWO OF THE FIRST
IN KIND.
ON PRODUCTS HAVE BEEN APPROVED
BY THE FDA JUSTICE PAST YEAR FOR
THE TREATMENT OF LEUKEMIA AND
LYMPHOMA.
WHILE ALL THIS WAS IN
DEVELOPMENT STURM SCIENTISTS HAD
ALREADY BEEN WORKING ON A WAY TO
OUR CREATE STEM CELL ARE IMMUNE
CELLS.
USING THIS TECHNOLOGY TO HAVE A
DURABLE AFFECT A LOT AGAINST THE
TOUGHEST SOLID CANCERS SUCH OF
THE BRAIN CANCER.
GLIOBLASTOMA.
AND CERTAIN LUNG CANCERS.
THE PROGRAM AT CITY OF HOPE AT
CITY OF HOPE.
HIS TARGETING GLIOBLASTOMA A
DATE DEADLY BRAIN CANCER AND
IT'S IT'S IT HAS BEEN PUBLISHED
IN THE NEW ENGLAND JOURNAL
JOURNAL OF MEDICINE FOR IT.
SOME REMARKABLE RESULTS AN
INITIAL PATIENTS.
THIS PROJECT IS THOSE ALSO
NOTABLE BECAUSE IT'S OUR SOURCE
OF THE FIRST ROYALTY CHECK DUE
TO A PARTNERSHIP OF THIS PROGRAM
WITH A COMMERCIAL ENTITY.
THAT WAS TO BAN THAT WHENCE I
HAVE --
AWARDED TO THE STATE IN
DECEMBER.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I CAN GO
ON AND ON ABOUT EVERY SINGLE
PROJECT THAT WE HAVE IS
SPECTACULAR AND AND JUST A
COUPLE YEARS AGO WHAT THEY HAVE
BEEN CONSIDERED SCIENCE FICTION.
BUT I JUST WANTED TO GIVE YOU A
SAMPLING FOR SOME OF THE DAY ON
TYPES OF PROGRAMS WE HAVE.
WE HAVE OTHER TYPES OF SELF
THERAPY AND JEAN PROGRAMS ARE
AGAINST.
THE MOST TOUGH INDICATION
[inaudible]
DISEASE STROKE AND NEUROLOGIC
DISEASE AS SO WHERE ARE WE TODAY
WE'RE QUITE ENCOURAGED THAT
THERE THERE'S SO MUCH.
PROGRESS BEING MADE IN THESE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES.
HOWEVER THERE ARE STILL MORE TO
DO.
I'M NOT ONLY WITH THESE
TECHNOLOGIES BUT IN THE NEXT
WAVE OF INNOVATION [inaudible]
SO.
JUST BY WAY OF BACKGROUND DOCTOR
SHINYA YAMANAKA WHO'S ONE OF
THAT STORM FUNDED --
SCIENTISTS AT THE GLADSTONE
INSTITUTE AT UCSF HAD RECEIVED
THE NOBEL PRIZE IN. TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE FOR HIS DISCOVERY THAT
ADULT STEM CELLS.
OUR OWN SKIN CELLS OR BLOOD
DRAWS CELLS OBTAINED FROM BLOOD
DRAWS CAN BE REPROGRAMMED.
BY RESETTING THE JEANS TO BECOME
STEM CELL LIKE.
SO THAT THOSE CELLS THAT YOU
REPROGRAM FROM CELLS COMING FROM
AS A SKIN BIOPSY.
CAN DOWN POTENTIALLY GIVE YOU AN
UNLIMITED SUPPLY OF THESE
PLURIPOTENCY MEANING CAN BE
TURNED INTO OTHER CELLS
[inaudible]
SO THIS.
PROSPECT OF HAVING READILY
AVAILABLE CELLS THAT CAN BE USED
FOR SOME OF THE TECHNOLOGY AT
TECHNOLOGIES I JUST DESCRIBED.
AS WELL AS FUTURE TECHNOLOGIES
AS A QUITE.
EXCITING ITS STILL IN ITS EARLY
FANS WE STILL DON'T HAVE A TRIAL
IN THE U. S. FOR I PSC ARM
DERIVED CELLS THERAPEUTICS.
DOCTOR YAMANAKA AS WELL AS OTHER
SCIENTISTS ARE CONTINUING TO DO
THE WORK TO OPTIMIZE CONDITIONS
TO THESE TYPES OF TECHNOLOGIES
CAN BE USED SAFELY IN PATIENTS.
IT IS A TANGIBLE AND UNFOUNDED
HOPE THAT THESE POOR UPON STEM
CELLS COULD GIVE RISE TO THE
NEXT WAVE OF THERAPIES.
AND IN FACT IN JAPAN ON THERE
ARE READY EARLY TRIALS LOOKING
AT I PSC THAT CAN BE TURNED INTO
NERVE CELLS THAT EXPRESSED
DOPAMINE WHICH IS MISSING AND
PARKINSON'S.
AS AN APPROACH TO PARKINSON'S
DISEASE.
THIS TECHNIQUE DEVELOPMENT OF
THIS TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY THE AYE
PSE TECHNOLOGY AWARD HIGHER THE
TYPE OF EARLY INVESTMENT.
EXPERTISE IN TRANSLATIONAL
RESEARCH AND SPECIALIZED SYSTEMS
BUT SERMONS PUT INTO PLACE.
I'D LIKE TO CLOSE WITH JUST
TALKING ABOUT [inaudible]
HOUSE TERMS.
PROCESSES AND VALUE PROPOSITION
HAS BEEN RECOGNIZED AND BY
OTHERS OUTSIDE OF SPERM
[inaudible]
IN INDUSTRY.
IN THE PAST INDUSTRY IN
TRADITIONAL INVESTORS HAVE BEEN
AND ARE NOT VERY ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT COMING IN EARLY SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE SCIENCE WAS. TO TWO
YOUNG --
THERE WERE TOO MANY UNKNOWNS AND
IT WAS A FINANCIAL RISK.
SO SIR ARM PLAYED THE ROLE OF
QUOTE UNQUOTE DE RISKING MEANING
WE FOUND THE BEST SCIENCE --
FUNDED THE INVESTIGATORS TO
PURSUE IT SO THAT THEY CAN GET
TO A STAGE WHERE THEY CAN TEST
IT AND A PROOF OF CONCEPT.
USING THIS MODEL.
WERE VERY PLEASED TO REPORT THAT
THIS HAS.
ATTRACTED INDUSTRY INVESTORS AND
PARTNERSHIPS COMMERCIALIZATION
PARTNERSHIPS FOR PROGRAMS AND
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF
THIS.
A PROJECT THAT WE US SUPPORTED
AT STANFORD IN ITS EARLY DAYS
WHILE STILL ON THE BENCH.
WAS BASED ON A CONCEPT THAT
THEIR CANCER STEM CELLS SO KIND
OF THE EVIL TWIN OF THE OTHER
STEM CELLS.
AND WE FUNDED THIS WHEN THE
CONCEPT WAS STILL DEBATED IN THE
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY.
TODAY IT'S NO LONGER DEBATED
IT'S ACCEPTED THAT THERE ARE
CANCERS STEM CELLS THAT THEY ARE
CRITICAL TO TARGET IF YOU'RE
GONNA TRULY YOUR THESE CANCERS.
AND ONE OF THE COMPANIES THAT
WAS THAT LICENSE THIS TECHNOLOGY
HAD JUST GONE PUBLIC RECENTLY
AFTER RAISING A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FINANCING.
SO IT MADE IT ALL THE WAY FROM
THE BENCH TO THE BEDSIDE TO A
COMMERCIAL PARTNERSHIP.
THIS IS JUST ONE OF THE EXAMPLES
OF HOUSE ARMED DOLLARS HAVE BEEN
LEVERAGED TO BRING IN ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS.
JUST A BED OVER HALF OF THE HALF
WAY MARK THIS YEAR ALONE.
WE'VE RECORDED OVER FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND
INDUSTRY PARTNERSHIP INVESTMENTS
INTO OUR PROGRAMS.
BRINGING OUR GRAND TOTAL TO OVER
ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
AND INDUSTRY INVESTMENT INTO
SOME FUNDED PROGRAMS.
IN FACT FOR THE TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS INSTRUMENT
WARRANTS.
THIS HAS BEEN LEVERAGED TO BRING
IN AN APPROXIMATE TWO POINTS
MATCHING TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN MATCHING FUNDS.
AND INVESTMENTS.
FROM OTHER SOURCES.
AND THE LAST --
TO KIND OF PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE
ARE CRAFTING ARE ALSO ESSENTIAL
BECAUSE THEY ARE BRINGING THESE
EFFORTS TO A GLOBAL STAGE.
WE HAVE FORMED PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE AND NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH JUST RECENTLY WE SIGNED.
A MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING.
BECAUSE AND I H. RECOGNIZES
THAT'S TERMS EXPERTISE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SYSTEM.
ARGUE NEATLY DESIGNED TO BRING
SCIENCE ALL THE WAY THROUGH
DEVELOPMENT SOMETHING THEY'RE
STILL TRYING TO GET TO
ESPECIALLY IN THIS YOUNG FIELD.
SO THEY'VE PARTNERED WITH US IN
THEIR FIVE YEAR CURE SICKLE CELL
INITIATIVE WHERE THEY WILL RELY
ON OUR EXPERTISE AND OUR FUNDING
MECHANISMS IN ORDER TO HELP
BRING THE BEST SCIENCE FORD.
PROCURED TO CURE SICKLE CELL.
THE FDA THAT HAS WHO HAVE
LAUNCHED --
THE REGENERATIVE MEDICINE
ADVANCED THERAPY DESIGNATION FOR
ACCELERATING --
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE TYPE OF
THERAPIES HAD GRANTED A
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH NUMBER
OF THESE DESIGNATIONS OF THESE
ACCELERATE PATHWAY TO STORM
FUNDED PROGRAMS.
IN FACT OF THE FIRST THREE
PROGRAMS THAT THE PROGRAM JUST
STARTED LAST YEAR.
OF THE FIRST THREE PROGRAMS TO
HAVE A MORE SARM --
OF THE FIRST FIFTEEN OR SO FOUR
OF THEM WERE SOME PROGRAMS.
SO THAT'S IN THE ENTIRE ENTIRE
UNITED STATES.
OKAY AT PROMINENT NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL CONFERENCES.
LEADERS FROM OTHER.
ORGANIZATIONS TO COME UP TO
SARM.
AND ARTICULATED THEIR NEED FOR A
CERTAIN TO SUCCEED THEY PERHAPS
STATED YOUR SUCCESS IS OUR
SUCCESS OF THIS FIELD IS GOING
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD.
THEY ARE RELYING ON US TO
MAINTAIN A LEADERSHIP POSITION
AND TO MAINTAIN A ROBUST
ACTIVITIES.
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE ALPHA
CLINICS NETWORK --
THAT WE'VE THAT WAS FORMED
PASSED LIKE THREE YEARS AGO THEY
FUNDING WE HAVE THAT WE'RE
SUPPORTING FIFTY SIX CLINICAL
TRIALS BUT MORE AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY THESE ARE
AMBASSADORS INTO HOW THESE
TECHNOLOGIES CAN BE BROUGHT INTO
MEDICAL PRACTICE.
AND THEY AND AND AND INTO THE
INSTITUTIONS IN A SAFE MANNER --
AND WITH AID LEARNING AND
SOURCES.
IN TERMS OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ALL THESE PROGRAMS
REPRESENT NOVEL MANUFACTURING BY
A MANUFACTURING UP CAPACITY THAT
IS BEING BUILT IN CALIFORNIA.
IN FACT ONE OF THE COMPANIES
THAT SPUN OUT OF OUR PROGRAMS
BUILT TO MANUFACTURING PROGRAMS
APPEAR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IN CONCLUSION SIR CALIFORNIA'S
THE BIRTH PLACE OF BY ATTACK.
BIOTECH BEING AN INDUSTRY THAT
USES THE NATURAL BIOLOGY OF
MICROORGANISMS TO PRODUCE
THERAPIES.
CALIFORNIA IT'S NOW THE LEAD IN
THE NEW FIELD OF REGENERATIVE
MEDICINE.
I FEEL THAT HARNESSES THE
NATURAL BIOLOGY OF THE HUMAN
CELL TO PRODUCE THERAPIES.
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY ARM
UNTREATABLE AND INCURABLE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION.
THANK YOU DOCTOR A LOT FOR THE
OVERVIEW AND YOU MENTIONED BIRTH
PLACE ABOUT TECHNOLOGY MY
HOMETOWN SAW SEVEN CISCO IS THE
BIRTH.
I WAS ON THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
FOR THIS AND IT ANYTIME ANY
OPPORTUNITY YOU HAVE MENTIONED
THAT WE MENTIONED ITSELF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR WHAT I WANT
--
TO ACKNOWLEDGE WE HAVE BEEN
JOINED BY A COUPLE OF MY
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TODD GLORIA.
AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARIE
WALDRON THANK YOU BOTH. FOR
BEING HERE THEY HAIL FROM THE
SAN DIEGO REGION --
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE --
THANK YOU DOCTOR MALIGNED LET'S
TURN -- TO
DAWN READ WITH THE ROMAN READ
FOUNDATION FOR SPINAL CORD
RESEARCH AND THEN WE'LL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK OUR PANEL
SOME QUESTIONS IF WE MAY.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
I'M THE FATHER OF PARALYZE YOUNG
MAN FROM AND READ AND THE AUTHOR
OF TWO BOOKS ON THE CALIFORNIA
STEM CELL PROGRAM.
IF YOU HAVE A CHRONIC DISEASE OR
PROVIDE CARE FOR SOMEONE WHO
DOES.
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE TO BE TOLD
THE CONDITION IS INCURABLE THERE
IS NO HOPE.
BUT BOB PLAYING INSPIRED AND LED
THE CITIZENS INITIATIVE
PROPOSITION SEVENTY ONE TWO
THOUSAND FOUR WE DID HAVE HOPE
LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
STEM CELL RESEARCH MIGHT
ALLEVIATE OR CURE MANY CHRONIC
ILLS AFFLICTING OUR LOVED ONES.
TODAY THANKS THE SEVEN POINT TWO
MILLION VOTERS WHO AUTHORIZED
THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
REGENERATIVE MEDICINE OR SIR.
WE HAVE SOMETHING BETTER THAN
HOPE.
WE HAVE RESULTS ACCOMPLISHMENTS
PEOPLE MADE WELL AND A
SYSTEMATIC WAY TO FIGHT CHRONIC
DISEASE.
HOW DOES IT WORK SCIENTISTS
APPLY FOR GRANTS ABORTED EXPERTS
FROM OUTSIDE THE STATE EVALUATES
PROPOSALS?
IN HOW SCIENTISTS GIVE THEIR
OPINIONS AND INDEPENDENT
CITIZENS OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE THE
BOARD.
WITH THE HELP OF THE PUBLIC
MAKES THE FINAL DECISION.
KAREN DISEASE IS NOT FAST
NOTHING IS GUARANTEED THERE WILL
BE SETBACKS.
BUT THE CERTAIN WAY IS LIKE A
FARMER PLANTING SEEDS.
RESULTS DO NOT COME OVERNIGHT.
BUT THE PROP PREPARATIONS ARE
DONE PROPERLY CURES.
LIKE CROPS CAN BECOME ALMOST
INEVITABLE.
IT IS HAPPENING NOW.
THERAPIES ARE DANCING.
PATIENTS ARE BENEFITING
KNOWLEDGE IS BEING SHARED OVER
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
MEDICAL DISCOVERIES HAVE BEEN
PEER REVIEWED AND PUBLISHED IN
SCIENTIFIC JOURNALS.
PIECES OF THE PUZZLE OF CARE.
CHILDREN'S LIVES HAVE BEEN SAVED
THIRTY BEAUTIFUL LITTLE
MUNCHKINS WHO CAN NOW RUN AROUND
OUTSIDE.
BEGIN THE SUNSHINE CURED
ACTUALLY CURED OF THE BUBBLE
BABY SYNDROME BEFORE THEY HAD NO
IMMUNE SYSTEM NOW THEY DO.
A YOUNG MAN CHRIS POISON
FORMALLY COMPLETELY PARALYZED IS
NOW LIFTING WEIGHTS.
HE RECEIVED A STEM CELL THERAPY
ORIGINALLY DEVELOPED BY THE
ROMAN REED SPINAL CORD INJURY
RESEARCH ACT OF NINETEEN NINETY
NINE AND ADVANCED BY SIR.
CHRIS POISSON RECOVERED THE USE
OF HIS ARMS AND HANDS THINK WHAT
THAT MEANS TO PARALYZE PERSON.
RENDON WHITTAKER HAD
GRANULOMATOSIS DISEASE A VICIOUS
CONDITION WHICH EATS AWAY THE
LUNGS AND LIVER.
HIS EARLY YEARS INVOLVED
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF TRIPS TO
THE HOSPITAL.
HIS CHANCES OF SURVIVING TO
ADULTHOOD WHICH WHEN HE HAD THE
DEATH SENTENCE.
BUT TODAY THANKS TO THERAPIES
DEVELOPED WITH ALBUS ARM BRENDAN
WOULD OCCUR LIVES.
WANTING TO PAY BACKS TERM FOR
HIS LIFE.
HE DECIDED TO BECOME A DOCTOR
NOW HE WILL HAVE ENOUGH YEARS
FOR THAT CAREER.
SAM IS PART OF MY FAVORITE
MEDICAL RESEARCH STORY IN
TORONTO CANADA THREE SCIENTISTS
ENTERED A BIG ROOM FULL OF YOUNG
PEOPLE AND BEDS.
WITH THEIR FAMILIES AROUND THEM
THE CHILDREN WHEN CALMNESS
[inaudible]
UNRESPONSIVE DYING.
BUT THE SCIENTIST HAD A NEW
SUBSTANCE TO TRY MAY FROM THE
PANCREAS IS OF DOGS.
WITH THE PARENTS PERMISSION THEY
START AT ONE END OF THE ROOM
INJECTING THE COMATOSE PATIENTS.
WHEN THEY REACHED THE FAR END
THE CHILDREN WHO GOT THE SHOT
FIRST WERE SITTING UP AND
TALKING TO THEIR ASTONISHED
PARENTS?
IT WAS INSULIN AND SAVE THEIR
LIVES.
BUT EVEN SO ALTHOUGH SHOTS THIS
WITH A TEMPORARY FIX NOT A
PERMANENT SOLUTION.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
CALIFORNIA DEVELOPED ARTIFICIAL
INSULIN AND TODAY SERMON IS
BUILDING ON THAT LEGACY.
DEVELOP SOMETHING LIKE AN
ARTIFICIAL PANCREAS TO BE
PERMANENTLY IMPLANTED IN THE
BODY WEARABLE CONVERT STEM CELLS
AND INSULIN.
AS FOR BERMAN MY SON CURE IS NOT
COME YET.
HE REMAINS PARALYZED WITH A
CHRONIC INJURY AND I AM HIS
CAREGIVER.
AT SEVENTY THREE MY HEALTH IS
GOOD.
BUT WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO HIM WHEN
I DIE.
I ACHE FOR HIM TO BE WELL TO DO
ALL THE THINGS ABLE BODIED FOLK
TAKE FOR GRANTED.
NO ONE SHOULD SUFFER WHEN HE
GOES TO EVERY DAY.
AND CALIFORNIA'S THREE MILLION
CITIZENS WITH A DISABILITY.
MAYBE IN YEARS TO COME
WASHINGTON WILL BECOME MORE
RESPONSIVE TO MEDICAL NEEDS OF
ALL OUR PEOPLE.
INCLUDING THE 50% OF OUR
POPULATION LIVING WITH AT LEAST
ONE CHRONIC DISEASE LIKE HEART
DISEASE CANCER STROKE OR
DIABETES.
BUT HOPE IS NOT ENOUGH WE CANNOT
SIT IDLY BY AND JUST WAIT.
WE NEED SOMETHING PROVEN
PRACTICAL AND HERE RIGHT NOW
SERVE.
THE GLORY OF THE STATE PRIDE OF
OUR NATION A FRIEND WHILE THE
WORLD.
PLEASE DO EVERYTHING IN YOUR
POWER TO SUPPORT PROTECT AND
RENEW THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE
FOR JANET MEDICINE THANK YOU.
JENNIFER IF I MAY USE ON THAT ON
THAT POINT MR GLORIA'S DISTRICT.
A VICE SITE COMPANIES LOCATED
AND IT'S ALL FOUND WORKING IN
THIS VERY TREATMENT A CURE FOR
DIABETES.
WE SPENT OVER FORTY BILLION AND
STATE ALONE A DIABETIC CARE SO
WE CAN DO ANYTHING ABOUT THAT IT
WOULD BE A TREMENDOUS.
A POSSIBILITY WHAT I'D NOW LIKE
TO HAVE YOU ASKED THE POPE WASH
THE FATHER OF OF RONNIE TO END
OUR PRESENTATION IF YOU CAN DO
THAT.
ARE THEY HERE.
HOPE.
THESE ARE THE PARENTS OF LOOK
FOR THEIR FUTURE TO THE FRONT
PAGE OF OUR ANNUAL REPORT.
THANK YOU MISREAD AND GIVE GIVE
OUR BEST TO YOUR SON AS WELL.
HERE THEY COME [inaudible]
THESE [inaudible]
BENEFIBER SELF [inaudible]
YES YEAH HI MY NAME IS SOUTH OF
WASHINGTON [inaudible]
AND HE'S [inaudible]
AT IT'S GOING TO MAKE IT
DIFFICULT --
HI MY NAME IS BUT WASHED AND
HE'S MY SON --
DO ENOUGH TO SHIP.
NOW WE GOT HIM RONNIE --
AND YES HE'S MY WIFE PLACENTA --
YEAH HE HE WAS GONE --
IN MARCY FALL SOME MERCY
HOSPITAL FOLLOWED SOME --
ON NOW MY TWO NINE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND IT WAS A GREAT DAY
EVERYTHING WAS GOING VERY GOOD.
AND FORTUNATELY WE HAVE A
NEWBORN SCREENING IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH YOU KNOW EVENTUALLY AFTER
LIKE FIVE DAYS OFF THAT
SCREENING HE WAS DEPICTED AS
GOOD -- SIVA
COMBINED IMMUNODEFICIENCY WE
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THE WORD WE
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THE PROBLEM.
WHEN WE HEARD ABOUT IT FOR THE
FIRST TIME WE GO LATE THEN?
NOTHING GOOD WAS COMING OUT OF
IT -- YOU
KNOW HOW WE WE SAW.
AND WIKIPEDIA THAT IT'S SAFE
BUBBLE BOY A DISEASE AND I
REMEMBER WATCHING ONE OF THE IN
EPISODE OF SEINFELD HAVING ABOUT
WILL BLAME IT SO I WAS REALLY
WHAT IT WHAT WHAT IS WHAT IS
GOING ON AND EVERYBODY WAS LIKE
[inaudible]
SHAKEN UP --
THAT IS WHEN --
YOU KNOW LIKE GUM --
WE CAME INTO.
I'M AS WE GOT A CALL FROM MOM
UCSF FROM ONE OF THE DOCTORS
DOCTOR JENNIFER BUG THAT YOU
KNOW WE COULD.
YOU HAVE TO BRING HIM OVER HERE
BECAUSE ANY KIND OF INFECTION
COULD KILL HIM --
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE TOO MANY
WEEKS.
EVEN NOT MANY LIKE MAYBE SIX OR
SEVEN WEEKS TO SURVIVE BECAUSE
HE HAS ANTIBODIES FROM HIS
MOTHER AS OF NOW.
BUT AS AS HE GROWS UP BUT AS HE
AS THE DAYS PASS IS ON IF YOU
GET ANY KIND OF INFECTION IT
WOULD BE HARD TO SURVIVE.
SO -- IT WAS
IT WAS VERY CHALLENGING IT WAS
LIKE -- YOU
KNOW BY JUST QUITE WITH IT ALL
SHAKEN UP AND MY MOM WAS HERE
FROM INDIA.
SHE WAS ALSO SHAKEN UP AND DOWN
WE EVENTUALLY WE LANDED UP TO
UCSF AND WE FOUND.
YOU KNOW THAT NOT MANY
TREATMENTS DAD HOW WE'VE BEEN
OFFERED BONE MARROW TRANSPLANT
FROM ME TO HIM.
NOW IT WAS THE FIRST AUDITION
BUT THEN --
BLESSING IN DISGUISE HE WAS.
FOUND AS ACTS LINK TO SKATE WITH
FOR THE TESTING.
AND THAT IS WHEN WE CAME TO KNOW
THAT --
SADDAM IS [inaudible]
TRY [inaudible]
SKID AND AND AND LOOKS LIKE THAT
IS THAT IS REALLY SUCCESSFUL
EVERYTHING IS GOING FINE AND AND
ALSO WE WE DID A LITTLE BIT OF
STARCH ON THE GENE THERAPY AND
WE FOUND THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT THERE WOULD BE THE FIX ON
THE YOU KNOW DNA AND THAT COULD
COME OUT OF FOR ANI WILL FIX THE
THING BECAUSE OF WHICH HE'S DE
SALES AND HIS BE SO THAT ARE
GROWING UP.
SO WE WERE REALLY THINKING YOU
KNOW SOMETHING WHICH CAN GO FROM
ME TO HIM GOOD PRO PROBABLY
BECAUSE A LOT OF PROBLEMS IN HIM
BUT SOMETHING WHICH WE CAN FIX
AND HAM AND WHEN IT'S GIVEN BACK
TO HIM PROBABLY THAT WOULDN'T
THERE WOULDN'T BE ANY KIND OF
PROBLEMS OUT.
OF IT.
SO THAT WAS A POSITIVE ATTITUDE
THAT WE ALSO HAD AND PLUS WE'RE
TALKING TO ALL THE DOCTORS OVER
THERE.
AND ALSO WE HEARD ABOUT THE
GRAFT VERSUS HOST DISEASE
SITUATION WITH THE BONE MARROW
TRANSPLANT WHICH WAS REALLY.
TIGHTENING AND WE'VE AT HITTING
LOT OF INFECTIONS HAPPENING
AFTER THAT.
SO GENE THERAPY WAS REALLY.
THE WAY TO GO AND THANK YOU TO
YOU KNOW SORRY MAN THANK YOU --
TO EVERYONE WHO HAVE CONTRIBUTED
TO ARTS THE UMP CLINICAL TRIALS
TOWARDS THE OF FINDING THE
SOLUTION TO THIS.
I YOU KNOW DEADLY DISEASE --
WE WE DID THE GENE THERAPY ON
JUNE EIGHT TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND AND THAT WAS THAT
WAS REALLY A BLESSING DAY FOR US
WE STARTED WE CAN PLACE THE
CELLS TO GROW UP.
AND BY BY SEPTEMBER FIFTH.
HE HAD FUNCTIONAL.
MORE THAN 5% OF THE CELLS IN HIS
BODY.
AND BY SEPTEMBER TALKING WEAVER
SAID THAT YOU KNOW BY UCS OF
THAT YOU CAN NOW LET CAN GO OUT.
PLAY AROUND ENJOYED THE BOY THEN
YOU KNOW SEE AROUND SO SEPTEMBER
THIRTEEN WE GOT DISCHARGED FROM
UCSF AND HE HAS BEEN HE HAS BEEN
DOING GREAT HE'S VERY ACTIVE
CHILD.
HE IS BE CELLS OF ALSO COME UP
NOW -- LIKE
LAST MONTH.
AND DEBBIE CELLS ARE GROWING
VERY FAST SO WE ARE PLANNING TO
A STOP THE THAT THAT IS THAT IS
--
ANTIBODIES THAT WE GIVE HIM
EVERY MONTH --
BECAUSE HIS BECAUSE OF THAT OUR
DEBT IT'S CALLED IVY ID.
AND DOCTORS UP RUNNING TO STOP
THAT AS WELL SO HE'S DIESEL THAT
FULLY FUNCTIONAL USE DIESEL HAVE
COMPLETELY GROWN UP LIKE A NOT
MUCH I HE IS PLAYING AROUND HIS
GOING AROUND HE HAS BEEN TO
CROWDS HE HAS BEEN TO ALL THE
MALLS.
USING FANTASTICALLY WELL USING
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU TO SHOW HIM
WHO HAS.
YOU KNOW WHO HAS BEEN AYE AYE
AYE WAS THAT AND I'M IN ONE OF
THE MEETINGS IN OAKLAND AND I
SAW.
THAT ALL THAT LEGAL TRIES WITH
SON HAS BEEN.
FUNDING AND I'M I'M REALLY
BLESSED AND WE ARE REALLY
BLESSED TO IN A ACCORDING TO ONE
OF THOSE CATEGORIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY AND YOUR BE
YOUR BABY BOY IS A BEAUTIFUL
COVER.
ON THE ON THE SERB ANNUAL
REPORTS A THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY AND WE WE
WISH YOU.
ALL THE BEST TO GET IT RIGHT.
SO WE DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
PERHAPS FOR THE FOR THE A PANEL
--
AND I'D WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES SINCE DOCTOR
PARK SHOWED A FIRST WILL GIVE
DOCTOR QUIRK THE FIRST QUESTION
--
SHOW FOR A DOCTOR MILIND PRETTY
PREENCHER LESSENING THE LAN
MILAN.
FARM.
BR QUESTION IS WHAT IS THE
CURRENT FEDERAL POLICY ON STEM
CELL RESEARCH.
I KNOW THAT INITIALLY --
THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION SAID
ONLY CERTAIN CELL LINES HAD
ALREADY BEEN PRODUCED COULD BE
YEARS [inaudible]
VAN.
ALTHOUGH I THINK IT WAS AN
EFFORT ON THAT ON THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION TO OPEN IT UP
SOME OF THE THINGS THEY DID.
LIKE --
HAVING -- A
CLEAR JUST --
DISCLOSURE TO THE PEOPLE WHO
DONATED THEIR CELLS SOME OF
THOSE LINES FAN COULDN'T BE USED
IT CETERA SO WHAT IS THE CURRENT
STATE WHAT'S WHAT'S THE STATE OF
WHAT OTHER.
IS THE FEDERAL RESEARCH
[inaudible]
ARE [inaudible]
HAVE ARTIFICIAL.
OF RESTRAINTS SUCH AS WE TALKED
ABOUT IS IT BEING A FUNDED OUT
WHAT IS THE CURRENT SITUATION
[inaudible]
SO -- SOME
OF THOSE RESTRICTIONS HAVE BEEN
LIFTED --
BUT WHERE WE ARE TODAY IS EVEN
WITH THAT THE NIH FOR INSTANCE
IS STILL NOT FUNDING GENERALLY
--
SOME OF THAT THE EMBRYONIC STEM
CELL RESEARCH.
A STURM IS FINDING EMBRYONIC
STEM CELL RESEARCH BUT ALSO.
7080% ARE THE NEW STEM CELL
DISCOVERIES THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
IN INDUCED PLURIPOTENT STEM CELL
HI MATIC GENE MODIFIED --
HEMATOPOIETIC STEM CELL THAT WE
SPOKE UP --
SO WHERE MORE DIVERSE AND THE
TYPES OF STEM CELL --
RESEARCH THAT WERE.
SUPPORTING IN CALIFORNIA THAT IS
BEING SUPPORTED NATIONALLY.
THEN IN RONNIE'S CASE YOU ALSO
--
RE USING GENETIC ENGINEERING.
ARM.
WERE USING VIRUSES TO OKC USING
IRISES IT WOULD HAVE ATLANTIC
VIRAL --
FACT THAT THERE WAS A VIRAL SO
IT'S A VIRAL THAT BECOMES.
INCAPACITATED IN TERMS OF ITSELF
BEING INFECTIOUS BUT IT JUST
SERVES AS A VEHICLE TO DELIVER
THE JEAN --
BUT I DON'T USES AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK ABOUT WE HAVE SOME UP
PROGRAMS WITHIN WITH AND THAT
NEXT GENERATION JEAN EDITING
CALLED CRISPER RIGHT WE'VE ALL
HEARD OF FOR VARIOUS INDICATIONS
AS WELL --
SO.
THERE'S QUITE IT'S JUST MOVING
AT LIGHTNING SPEED IN TERMS OF
THE IMPROVEMENTS AND THE
SPECIFICITY BY WHICH GENES CAN
BE EDITED AND THAT --
BUT THERE IS SOME QUITE A BIT OF
ACTIVITY AROUND OF GETTING THE
BEST FACTORS MAKING THIS SO IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S PRACTICAL THAT
CAN BE CREATED INTO A PRODUCT
THAT.
IS NOT SO CUMBERSOME THAT IT'S
NOT PRACTICALLY ABLE TO GET OUT
THE PATIENTS SO THAT THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE KIND OF THE
UNDERLYING ACTIVITIES BEHIND THE
SCIENTIFIC AS WELL AS THE
CLINICAL TRIAL.
ARE ALL OF THOSE COMPONENTS
ACTIONS ON FLORA.
STEM CELLS.
OTHER RESEARCH OF THAT TYPE.
I'M GENE THERAPY RESEARCH WELL
GENE THERAPY BUT JUST THE U.
SUPPLIER PLOWDEN STEM CELLS
OPPOSED EMBRYONIC STEM CELLS.
NOT NOT CURRENT IN TERMS OF THE
INDUCED PLURIPOTENT STEM CELLS
NUMBER NO OF RESTRICTIONS ON
THAT IS JUST THE SCIENCE THAT
NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO MATURE.
AND WHAT I HAD MENTIONED KINDA
BRIEFLY --
WHAT UNIQUELY THIS STORM DOES
PURSES WHAT THAT OTHER AGENCIES
THAT SUPPORT THIS TYPE OF
RESEARCH FROM?
WHAT IT'S REALLY QUITE
REMARKABLE BECAUSE THERE MAY BE?
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE TYPE OF
RESEARCH HAS BEEN FUND IT LOOKS
LIKE IT'S BEING FUNDED?
BUT WHEN YOU TALK TO THE
SCIENTISTS BUT WHAT HAPPENS IS
WHEN THEY HAVE THE SCIENTIFIC
DISCOVERY THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT.
WE GET THIS SO IT DEVELOPED INTO
SOMETHING WE GET TOUGH IN A
CLINICAL TRIAL NOTED THAT.
THAT.
THAT KIND OF PHASE CALLED THE
TRANSLATIONAL PHASE.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE NIH ARM
IS DON'T REALLY TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO THAT ESPECIALLY IN
THIS.
IN THIS ARENA COUNTY THAT'S TERM
--
HAD THAT BIG WE BECAME
SPECIALIST SENATE AND THE THE
REASON THAT THEY ARE PARTNERING
WITH US FOR THE CURE SICKLE CELL
INITIATIVE AND WERE IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM ABOUT
OTHER TYPES OF POTENTIAL
PARTNERSHIP.
BECAUSE THAT BECAUSE THEY
REALIZE THAT WE JUST HAD IT WAS
BUILT BY DESIGN FOR THESE TYPE
OF TREATMENTS TO GET THEM OUT TO
THE PATIENTS.
SO -- I
THINK THAT IT WOULD REGARDLESS
OF TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM AND AND
EVERYTHING ELSE WHAT WE HAVE IS
A VERY RELIABLE SYSTEM.
AND VERY DE LA DEEP EXPERT
INTERNALLY AS WELL AS WITH OUR
SCIENTIFIC REVIEWERS AND
ADVISERS --
REGULATORY ADVISORS DEVELOPMENT
--
EXPERTS TO HELP US WITH ALL
THESE PROGRAMS OKAY WE'VE
CONVINCED ME YOU HAVE A UNIQUE
--
SPOT IN THE I RESEARCH
ENVELOPMENT AREA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DUCT WORK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
I'M JUST ALWAYS SO ENERGIZED
WHEN I HEAR ABOUT THE NEW
INNOVATIONS OF SYSTEM CREDIBLE
--
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU KNOW
WE HAD LEARNED IN THE PAST --
WHEN I DID IT SEVERAL TOURS UMP
OF DIFFERENT --
COMPANIES ADDED.
TO SOME OF THESE NEW.
YOU KNOW IT EITHER GENE THERAPY
OR A MINHA THERAPY --
WAS ONE OF THE ISSUES OF
DIAGNOSES ARE A LOT OF TIMES
WITH RARE DISEASE SOMETIMES IT
COULD TAKE IN UP TO EIGHT YEARS
BEFORE PEOPLE FIGURE OUT WHAT IT
IS BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE
AVERAGE PHYSICIAN IS NOT.
NO MAY NEVER HAVE SEEN THAT
BEFORE OR YOU KNOW PATIENTS AND
MEDICARE ALL YOU KNOW THERE IN
THE CLINIC ARE HOW DID THEY GET
TO SOMEONE WHO CAN FINALLY
DIAGNOSE THE ISSUE --
YOU KNOW MOVED ALL TALKED ABOUT
IN DOING THAT EARLY SCREENING.
WHEN A BABY IS BORN WHICH IS
GREAT THAT YOU KNOW THAT WAS
AVAILABLE AND I DON'T KNOW IF
EVERY?
NEWBORN HAS AN OPPORTUNITY AND
YOU KNOW HOW HOW MANY OF THESE
GENES CAN WE GET THAT EARLY
DIAGNOSIS FOR AN EARLY
SCREENING.
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW WHERE WE
ARE WITH THAT USE YOU KNOW FAR
AS A GOAL.
I THINK IF YOU BRING UP A AND
AND AND AND A VERY IMPORTANT --
CONSIDERATION AND AT IT AS A
PEDIATRIC ORGAN TRANSPLANT
SURGEON.
UP THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
DEFINITELY APPRECIATED --
THAT ABILITY TO PREDICT WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN AND AND IN THESE
BABIES EVEN BEFORE THEY'RE BORN.
BUT IN SOME CASES AS YOU SAY
IT'S NOT RECOGNIZE TO LATER AND
THEN THERE IS ED THAN THAN THAT
WORK UP OCCURS.
I THINK THAT THERE IS --
AND GREG ENDS WHOSE AT STANFORD
IS A IS A AS A GENETICIST AND
THE METABOLIC EXPERT WAS ONE OF
THEM THE KEY PLAYERS IN TERMS OF
HELPING BRING FORWARD SOME OF
THE THAT.
THE SCREENING SOUTH IT WAS FOR
FUN ARE MINE. ONE OF THE KEY
THINGS AND ADVANCEMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE IS THIS.
A IDEA OF THE REASON WE'RE ABLE
TO DO GENE THERAPY IS BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THE HUMAN GENOME --
BETTER NOW.
WE UNDERSTAND THE HUMAN GENOME
BETTER NOW BECAUSE IT WAS A
DELIBERATE.
INITIATIVE IN THE NINETIES. TO
MAP THE HUMAN GENOME.
THE ABILITY TO MANIPULATE GENES.
AND CELLS IN THE BODY IS MADE
POSSIBLE BY THE DISCOVERY THAT
LED TO THE NOBEL PRIZE
[inaudible]
THAT WAS.
DON ON MOUSE EMBRYONIC STEM
CELLS THAT THE FIRST TIME IT WAS
NOTED THAT YOU COULD ACTUALLY
MANIPULATE THE GENES AND COME UP
WITH A DIFFERENT EFFECT.
THE MOST NOBEL PRIZE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN OR SO.
ALL EVERY EVERY SINGLE DISCOVERY
ALL THESE ADVANCEMENTS ARE
BUILDING ON EACH OTHER SO.
IN TERMS OF GENETIC SCREENING IN
TERMS OF BETTER UNDERSTANDING
WHAT'S GOING ON SARM FOR
INSTANCE HAD FUNDED THAT OJ A
GENOMICS PROGRAM TOGETHER.
AND SPECIFIC INDEPTH LOOK AT
JUST TO THEM VERY VERY VERY --
FINE DETAILS OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THE CELLS AND
DISEASE STATES AS WELL AS AN AND
HEALTHY STATE.
WE CREATED AND AND I SEM INDUCED
PLURIPOTENT STEM CELL BANK WITH
TWO THOUSAND THREE THOUSAND
LINES THAT CAN BE USED. TO
ELUCIDATE DISEASES SUCH AS
AUTISM JUST REALLY REALLY --
INDEPTH ANALYSIS TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF WHERE THE
TECHNOLOGY IS WITH BIG DATA AND
AND MACHINE LEARNING AND DEEP
LEARNING TO THERE'S STILL MORE
TO DO.
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
THAT IT'S NOT STEM SELLER SELF
THERAPY IN ISOLATION.
IT'S KNOWING THE BIOLOGY AND
INTEGRATING IT WITH ALL THE
OTHER ADVANCEMENTS IN SCIENCE
AND SO. FOR INSTANCE AND ONE OF
THE CHILD I MENTIONED AND THAT
AND THE CHILD AT THE CITY OF
HOPE WITH GLIOBLASTOMA.
NOT ONLY IS THIS AMAZING
TECHNOLOGY OF AN ENGINEERED
IMMUNE CELLS THAT SPECIFICALLY
TARGETS THESE CANCER CELLS --
BEING DEVELOPED BUT AS THAT
PARALLEL STUDIES IN COMPUTATION
--
AT PREDICTIONS AND GENOMICS
PROFILES OF WHAT THE CANCER'S
GOING THROUGH SO IF SOMETHING
DOES HAPPEN IF IT RECURS OR
SOMETHING ELSE.
NOW THERE'S MORE INFORMATION TO
GUIDE --
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE TECHNOLOGY
[inaudible]
SO.
KIND OF A LONG WINDED ANSWER BUT
I THINK IT IT IT'S IT'S IT THAT
SPEAK TO YOUR RIGHT COMES FROM A
VERY BASIC UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
DEALING WITH MAKING SURE POLICY
IS COMPATIBLE WITH ALLOWING US
TO GET THAT MAKING SURE THE
INFORMATION IS OUT THERE SO CAN
BE USEFUL MY REFUND FORTY
MILLION TO THAT.
GENOMICS INSTITUTE WHICH IS.
STANFORD WHICH IS THAT IT GROWS
AND LISTENING SAN DIEGO.
WHILE SOLICITS INSULT INSTITUTE
THE EARLIER YOU CAN DIAGNOSIS
THAT EARLIER IN THE BETTER YOU
KNOW THE YOUNGER THE PATIENTS
THEM THE BETTER.
YOU ABSOLUTELY OUTCOME --
DISMAY AND JUST REALLY BRIEFLY
MY LAST QUESTION WITH AS FAR AS
BARRIERS I MEAN WILL.
YOU KNOW THERE'S ALWAYS BARRIERS
TO GETTING.
THE INNOVATIONS TO THE BEDSIDE
--
COST.
ACCESS HOME YOU KNOW INVESTMENT.
MONEY YOU KNOW OPEN WHAT ARE THE
BARRIERS ARE SEEING YOU KNOW HOW
CAN WE HELP THOSE OF STATE
LEGISLATURE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT OF THOSE
THINGS NOW THAT.
WE HAVE INNOVATIONS WERE
CONTINUING TO GROW AND LEARN.
IN HOW CAN WE GET THAT TO THE
PATIENT.
AND I KNOW ACCESS TO THE BIGGEST
TO YEAH I KNOW IT'S A NO BECAUSE
NO I I I THINK IT'S SUCH AN
IMPORTANT THAT SUCH AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION BECAUSE THAT IS OUR NEW
CHALLENGE IN ADDITION TO THE
SCIENTIFIC.
FRONTIER AND OPPORTUNITIES OF
THE POLICY AND AND ACCESS ISSUES
THAT ARE GONNA BE.
AT IT AND I CAN'T GO HAND IN
HAND WITH ALL OF THIS IN FACT WE
ARE ENABLING OUR INVESTIGATORS
WHEN THEY'RE DOING THE CLINICAL
TRIALS NOW. TO START GETTING
ACCESS TO HELP TOOLS SORTS ARE
DEVELOPING THEIR TECHNOLOGIES
THERE THEY ARE BETTER AWARE OF
ALL THE THINGS WEATHER'S
REGARDING THEIR MANUFACTURING
WHAT THE REGARDING HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO GET OUT THERE TO THE
PATIENTS.
ALL THOSE FINE DETAILS SO THAT
THEY DESIGN DESIGN THE TYPES OF
PRODUCTS COULD THAT I CAN
ACTUALLY WILL REACH THE PATIENTS
IN THE AND IT DOESN'T DO ANYBODY
ANY GOOD IF YOU HAVE SOMETHING
THAT WORKS FOR YOU CAN GET A TO
THE PATIENTS.
HOW DO YOU --
I MEAN BECAUSE THE PROBLEM OF
LUCK I SUPPOSE SIT ON HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND YOU KNOW IT ALWAYS
COMES UP TO HOW TO PROVIDERS
EVEN KNOW THAT THESE TREATMENTS
EXIST HOW WITH THE EDUCATED.
YOU KNOW IN CONTINUING EDUCATION
BECAUSE EVERY TIME WE TRY TO ADD
SOMETHING TO CONTINUING
EDUCATION THE MEDICAL BOARD AS
AN ISSUE WITH.
YOU KNOW DOING IT AND YOU KNOW
IF YOU'RE A MOM WHO DOESN'T
SPEAK ENGLISH IN AN INNER CITY.
YOU KNOW HOW IT IN A MEDICAL
CLINIC HOW ARE THEY EVER GOING
TO KNOW THAT THIS EXISTS FOR
THEIR CHILD THAT'S A THAT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION AS A
FORMER CHAIR OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE I UNDERSTAND THE
FRUSTRATION THAT.
THAT YOU SHARE UP IT NUMBER ONE
THE INITIATIVE.
CALLS THAT IF ANYONE NEEDS A
TREATMENT THAT IS DEVELOPED BY
PUBLIC FUNDS.
AND THEY CANNOT AFFORD IT THEY
ARE ENTITLED TO IT IF THEY'RE
LIVING CALIFORNIA AND RESIDENT
CALIFORNIA.
SECONDLY MY OTHER HAT IS AYE SIR
PRO BONO IS ONE OF FIVE MEMBERS
OF THE BOARD OF COVER CALIFORNIA
WHICH OVERSEES THE A CA IN THE
STATE.
SO WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
CONVERSATIONS IN SEPTEMBER WITH
OUR GUYS ON THE COVER CALIFORNIA
SIDE WHO NEGOTIATE CONTRACTS
WITH THIRD PARTY PAYERS TO LET
THEM KNOW AHEAD OF TIME WHAT
TREATMENTS MAY BE COMING DOWN
THE ROAD.
AND TRIED TO EXPLAIN TO THEM
THAT MANY OF THESE TREATMENTS
MAY BE EXPENSIVE BUT FIRST.
BUT IN THE LONG RUN THEY'RE
GONNA END UP SAVING MONEY AS
PROVIDERS COULD YOU NOT COULD BE
SPENDING FORTY BILLION FOR
EXAMPLE FOR DIABETES OR OR
ANOTHER DISEASE.
AND THAT'S HOW WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO BEGIN THE EDUCATIONAL
PROCESS.
BECAUSE ONE SEES CLINICAL TRIALS
ARE DONE ONE SEES TREATMENTS ARE
APPROVED THEN WE'RE GOING TO BE
READY TO GO OUT INTO THE INTO
THE FORCE OUT THERE AND MAKE
SURE THE PEOPLE ARE AWARE.
OF WHAT TREATMENTS ARE AVAILABLE
NUMBER ONE AND ACCESSIBILITY
WHICH IS THAT AS YOU START STATE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT.
SMASHED GLORIA PICKING AS
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU THE PANEL
SENATOR GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE
THANK.
MISS VAUGHN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND MISTER PREEMPTED OF
TESTS SPROUTS A CRACKLING YEAH
I'M THANK YOU FOR YOUR STORY AYE
ISM.
YEAH I I'M NOT A HEALTH EXPERT
I'M A SCIENTIST IN A BLUEBOOK
GUY NOT SCANTRON GUY --
AND SO --
YOU'RE THE PERSONAL STORY IS
JUST SO VALUABLE SO I KNOW
WHATEVER TIME YOU TAKE WITH MORE
CLEAR ACTUAL LIFE FOR JUST
LOOKING AT YOUR YOU BOY.
OF ITS CASE STREAMING HELPFUL
FOR SOME OF US OF THIS ON A
PROBE HASN'T YOU KNOW HAS.
SOME WEIGHT OR SOME ABILITY TO
WEIGH IN ON THE STAFF OF FREE TO
SHARE YOUR PERSONAL TYPE OF THE
PERSONAL IS POLITICAL AS WITH
BATES OFTEN LIKE TO SAY AND SO
--
THIS THIS STOCK IS ACTUALLY
REALLY REALLY HELPFUL BUT YOUR
STORY IS IS INVALUABLE TO MY
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THIS MEANS
FOR PEOPLE SO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME SHUT THINKING
HERE IN ARIZONA.
ON THIS BEFORE ACTUALLY SUPER
HELPFUL WELL I WOULD JUST SAY I
WISH WE COULD LOOK AT THAT
BECAUSE THE EIGHT I KNEW IN THE
LEGISLATURE BAG AND UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S GOING ON JUST LOOK AT
CRISSY LOOK AT THIS --
BECAUSE I'M NOT A PART HEALTH
LET ME ASK WILL BE ABOUT THE
FINANCIALS AND I TOOK NO --
MS MONT OF YOUR COMMENT ABOUT
THAT RETURN ON INVESTMENT YOU
START TO SEE A ROYALTY PAYMENT
WAS THAT THE WAY YOU PHRASED IT
--
SO WE HAVE THE FIRST ROYALTY
CHECK TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IT WAS THIS YOU KNOW IT WAS US
THIS INITIAL SMALL AMOUNT ONE
HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND FROM
FOUGHT BUT IT JUST.
WHAT IT THE SIGNIFICANCE IS THAT
IT'S THE MODEL THAT WORKS RIGHT
THERE'S NO OTHER FUNDING AGENCY
THAT HAS THAT BUILT THEN WHAT
THERE'S A REPORT THAT WHERE
THERE'S A RETURN ON THAT ON THE
AWARD --
THERE ARE MORE PAYMENTS
REGARDING THAT PARTICULAR
PROJECT BUT ALL ARE PROJECTS --
HAVE ROYALTY --
PROVISIONS ATTACHED TO THE GRANT
OKAY AND IF THEY GET AND THEN
THERE IS A LOAN CONVERSION
OPTION FOR THAT AND WHICH CASE
THERE IS A LOAN WITH INTEREST
THE GETS PAID BACK.
AND THEN THAT THAT COMES BACK
INTO.
HE ALSO STATED BANG YOU MISSED
MY INCREDIBLE TESTIMONY I'M SURE
WELCH HAS WHAT YOU THINK MY
OFFICE SO.
WASN'T I MISSED IT DIDN'T GET IN
REAL LIFE.
THE OTHER IMPACT WHICH I KNOW
YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IS THAT
THIS AGENCY HAS CREATED FORTY
TWO HUNDRED JOBS.
IN CALIFORNIA AND TWO HUNDRED
EIGHT MILLION TO THE STATE.
A GENERAL FUND IT TAX REVENUE
AND ANOTHER FORTY TWO POINT
EIGHTY TWO POINT SIX MILLION TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHICH I KNOW
THAT'S WHERE YOU CAN GET HIM.
AND FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION. TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO THE AGENCY AS
OPPOSED TO ANY OTHER STATE
AGENCY IS GENERATING REVENUE AND
CREATING JOBS.
BY LEVERAGING THE ONE POINT SIX
BILLION IN GRANTS THAT WE'VE
ISSUED ALREADY.
WITH ALMOST ONE POINT SIX
BILLION AND PRIVATE DONATIONS
THAT WE'VE LEVERAGED AS AS WE
HAVE STOOD POINT SEVEN TO POINT
TWO POINT SEVEN RIGHT.
THAT'S ABOUT ECONOMIC IMPACT
REPORT.
SO YOU GOT YOUR FIRST ROYALTY
CHECK YES NOW IS THAT.
AND WHAT WHAT IS WHAT OF
ROYALTIES ARE.
WHAT ROLE THEY PLAY IN THE
FINANCIAL?
FUTURE OF THIS ORGANIZATION OF
THIS OF THIS A ADDITION.
I THINK THE SHORT ANSWER IS THAT
WE WON'T HAVE ANY MAJOR ROLE IN
THIS PARTICULAR.
YEAH FROM THE PROP SEVENTY ONE
IN THE CURRENT AGENCY BUT I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT WAS
DESIGNED FOR THAT PURPOSE NAM.
SO.
I THINK THAT IN THE BEGINNING OF
THE UP OF THIS ON A SESSION IT
WAS MENTIONED THAT WE HAVE AS A
FINITE.
FUNDING BASED ON THE THREE
BILLION DOLLAR ALLEN AND WHERE
WE ARE RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF OUR
SUCCESS AND FUNDING THESE.
CLINICAL TRIALS WE EXPECT THAT
OUR RESEARCH FUNDING BUDGET WILL
BE EXPENDED BY TO THE OTHER --
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE STILL
HAVE ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS THAT
CAN MAKE SURE THAT THESE
PROGRAMS CAN CONTINUE BEYOND
THAT REGARDLESS OF YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS BEYOND THAT --
FOR THE PERIOD FOR THE DURATION
OF THE WARRANTS ARE CLINICAL
WHAT'S ABOUT FOUR YEARS --
SO THE ROYALTY PER.
GOES BACK TO THE STATE IT
DOESN'T COME BACK DECIRME --
THERE ARE SOME INSTANCES WHERE.
SOME FUNDS COME BACK TO STORM
HIDING GO INTO DETAIL BUT PART
OF OUR KIND OF OUR PROCESS WHICH
HAS BEEN --
OF REALLY EFFICIENT WAY OF
MAKING SURE THE MONEY GOES TO
WHERE IT NEEDS TO GO IS THAT WE
HAVE MILESTONE BASED PAYMENTS.
SO THAT WE DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO
HELP OUR GRANTEES ACHIEVE THE
MILESTONES BECAUSE THAT MEANS
THEY'RE DOING WELL IN THE
PROJECT BUT IF FOR SOME REASON
IT JUST CAN'T WORK OUT THE
SOMETIMES THINGS DON'T WORK OUT.
ITS BUILT IN THAT THAT MONEY
COMES BACK IN TO THE RESEARCH
FUND SO THAT IT CAN BE DEPLOYED
TO OTHER PROGRAMS.
OR EVEN TO THAT SAME PROGRAM
SHOULD THAT FIX IT YOU KNOW GET
WHATEVER'S --
THE HOLD UP FIX NOT COME BACK
AGAIN WITH ANOTHER APPLICATION
SO THAT'S YOU KNOW I JUST.
IT KIND OF HOW WE BE CYCLE NOT
RECYCLE BUT USE FUNDS MORE
RESPONSIBLY BUT SO FROM READING
THE REPORT CORRECTLY YOU HAVE
THREE AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION
LEFT.
THAT YOU CAN ALLOCATE.
THAT WAS THAT BY THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO
PASSED AWAY TODAY.
TODAY WE WERE PROBABLY
ACCOUNTABLE OR EXACTS A PROXY
BALLPARK ABOUT TO TO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OVER TWO TWENTY OR
SOUND.
AND SO THEN WE I THINK YOU
UNDERSTAND I'M TRYING TO GET OUT
OR MAYBE CLUMSILY GETTING TO ON
THE WHICH IS --
RESILIENCE YOUR SYSTEM BILLET
RIGHT OR ON GOING RIGHT THE WORK
IS NOT DONE THEIR MORE YOU KNOW
DISEASE'S SNEAKERS AND AND KIDS
THAT NEED HELP RIGHT SO WHAT IS
THE WHAT IS THE PLAN FOR THAT
LONG TERM FINANCIAL STABILITY OF
THE ORGANIZATION.
TARA'S TO TAKE THAT.
AS A STATE AGENCY WE CANNOT GET
INVOLVED IN POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS
BUT THAT DOESN'T PREVENT BOB
KLEIN WHO WROTE THE INITIAL IT
INITIATIVE.
WHO FOUNDED AMERICANS FOR CURES
AND THEY ARE PROCEEDING?
OUGHT TO CONSIDER PUTTING ON THE
BALLOT IN TWENTY TWENTY A NEW
INITIATIVE --
AFTER THEY COLLECT THE
SIGNATURES TO QUALIFY ISN'T THE
ONLY OPTION.
AT THIS POINT YES.
I AM A BE INTERESTING CAN THAT
CONVERSATION I GET HOW THAT'S
PROBABLY OF EFFECTIVE AND GETS
TO THE CAT SCALE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
ARM AND I AT THE WEALTHY THAT IS
ME ONLY GOVERNMENT AND HUNDRED
AND NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS NOT
SOUND LIKE A LOT OF MONEY BUT I
ALL OF US LIKE ANYTHING --
HOWEVER I RECOGNIZE IT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO TO FUND INNOVATION OF
THIS NINETY TWO WITH THE SCIENCE
THE EXPENSES THAT COME WITH IT
ALSO KNOW AND I APPRECIATE THE
CHALLENGE BOXES ON THIS REPORT
THAT LAYS OUT FOR FOLKS LIKE US
TO KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DEALING
WITH.
AND YOU KIND OF GOT THIS A
MINUTE AGO SENATOR ABOUT THAT --
ABILITY --
TO SO I MEAN ALL THIS IS IN
THERE BUT IT'S JUST THE STORY IS
AND I KNOW IT'S ALL IT'S
ILLUSTRATIVE OF MANY OTHERS ARMS
WE WANT TO KEEP THAT GOING IN
AND CONTINUED FRANKLY OUR BRAND
OF BEING INNOVATORS IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT --
SO ANYWAY.
FANTASTIC STUFF PLEASE KEEP IT
UP AND LET US KNOW WHAT WE CAN
DO TO BE HELPFUL WITHIN THE
LEGAL BY THE WHAT YOU COULD SAY
INSIDE THIS BUILDING THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU.
THEY WAS GLORIA --
WHILE WE STILL HAVE YOU AT THE
TABLE WE WE LEARNED HOW MUCH
BOND FUNDING IS LAUGHS --
WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT TWENTY
TWENTY BALLOT APPARENTLY PRIVATE
EFFORT ANY SIZE OF BOND THAT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED ARE YOU.
IT IS MISTER KLEIN LOOKING IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF THREE
BILLION IS LOOKING NEIGHBORHOOD.
FIVE FIVE BILLION YES.
AND HAVE OTHER STATES FOLLOW
CALIFORNIA'S LEAD IN THIS REGARD
ME TALK ABOUT THE AND I AGE
FUNDING THE FEDERAL PICTURE.
OF OTHER STATES THAT CHASING A
THIS INDUSTRY --
OR IS CALIFORNIA'S STILL VERY
MUCH AN AL LIAR.
MANY STATES HAVE ATTEMPTED --
AND THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE
STILL IN EXISTENCE BUT THE
BUDGETS ARE AND KNOW WHERE.
YOU KNOW AND THAT'S THAT IS YOU
KNOW THE MAJOR LIMITATION --
AND ANOTHER THING THAT HAS HELD
UP SOME OF THESE EFFORTS ARE
THERE IT OFTEN --
SHORT TERM ALLOCATIONS
[inaudible]
AND ONE OF THE AT THE ADVANTAGE
IS THAT THE SERVER MODEL HAS
ALLOWED US IS IT'S ALLOW US TO
DEPLOY THE FUNDING WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE BECAUSE THERE IS A
SCIENCE BASED OPPORTUNITY.
RATHER THAN HAVING AN ARTIFICIAL
YOU KNOW KIND OF LIMITATION.
THAT'S BUDGETARY OR TIME BASED
--
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT ALSO
THE NIH RECOGNIZES A HUGE
ADVANTAGE.
NAM FOR INSTANCE THAT BILLET.
EIGHT TO GET THE MILESTONE BASED
PAYMENTS AT THEIR NOT MET BACK
IN AND REDEPLOY IT.
OFTEN AND THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT THEY DO BECAUSE WHEN IT
COMES BACK AND IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY GO TO ANY YOU KNOW
IN ANY PREDICTABLE WAY BACK TO
THEIR PROGRAMS AND I'LL JUST GO
BACK.
INTO THE MORE GENERAL FUND SO --
THERE BEEN A MARYLAND IS STILL
HAS A SMALL EFFORT THERE LIKE I
THINK OF TWO OR THREE FTA EASE
--
NEW JERSEY HAD ATTEMPTED I DON'T
THINK IT WAS RE UP THIS YEAR NEW
YORK -- I
THINK THEY LOST THEIR FUNDING
IT'S JUST HAD A REAL PROBLEM
ACCESS TO ALL THE BOARD MEMBERS
WERE APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR.
BUT IT THAT THERE ARE ATTEMPTS
BUT BUT THE AND SOME OF THEM ARE
MAKING AT DELAWARE STARTING TO
TIP.
RAZOR VISIBILITY IN TERMS OF
MANUFACTURING --
BUT STORM IS KIND OF UNIQUE IF
THE ONLY ONE IT'S ONLY ONE OUT
THERE IN THE IN THE WORLD
ACTUALLY.
AND FINAL QUESTION BECAUSE WE
DON'T NEED TO ACCELERATE THE
HEARING JUST A LITTLE BIT OF THE
RESULT ARTICLE IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO CHRONICLE ABOUT ON
REGULATED STEM CELLS CLINICS AN
ISSUE THAT I'M SURE YOU.
HAVE BEEN AWARE OF IT WAS NEW
HOT TO ME WHEN I READ THAT
ARTICLE I GUESS THESE STEM CELL
UNREGULATED STEM CELL CLINICS
ARE PROLIFERATING.
GETTING SOME ADDITIONAL SCRUTINY
CONCERNS FROM --
YOU BOTH ABOUT.
BUT REGULATED CLINICS IS A
SOMETHING THE LEGISLATURE OUGHT
TO BE LOOKING AT THERE'S
CERTAINLY A FEDERAL COMPONENT
HERE RIGHT BUT DOING CALIFORNIA
NEED TO BE I AM WELL LAST ACTING
ON THIS YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
AND AND S. B. FIVE TWELVE WHICH
WAS SIGNED BY.
GOVERNOR BROWN YET LAST YEAR
THIS YEAR.
RATHER LAST YEAR TOOK EFFECT
JANUARY ONE BY SENATOR HERNANDEZ
WHO IS THE CHAIRMAN SENATE --
HEALTH COMMITTEE.
AND IT SAYS THAT TO EVERY
HEALTHCARE PRACTITIONER WHO IS
NOT APPROVED BY THE FDA MUST NOW
GIVE A NOTICE. TO ANY POTENTIAL
PATIENT THAT THEY ARE NOT.
REGULATED BY THE FDA NOR
APPROVED AND REGULATIONS WILL
PROVIDE IN FINES TO THAT
ORGANIZATION AND A RECORD SHALL
BEGIN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN FROM THEM BORDER
MEDICAL QUALITY ASSURANCE OF THE
REPORTS NOT READY YET. TO FIND
OUT HOW MANY COMPLAINTS HAVE
BEEN ISSUED A AGAINST CERTAIN
PRACTITIONERS THE OTHER PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE A STANDSTILL
TERRORISTS.
WHERE PEOPLE ADVERTISE FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD WHETHER IT'S THE
CARIBBEAN WHETHER IT'S MEXICO
WHETHER IT'S ASIA WE HAVE THE
TREATMENT FOR YOU AND WE CAN
HEAL YOU?
THAT'S MORE DIFFICULT FOR US
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T RESTRICT A U.
S. CITIZENS RIGHT TO TRAVEL THEY
THINK THEY'RE GOING TO BE
HEALED.
AND SO ALL WE CAN DO IS WARN
PEOPLE AHEAD OF TIME.
THAT NO THERE THERE ISN'T A A
CURE FOR WHAT YOU WANT TO FIND A
CURE FOR THAT WE KNOW OF AND
SOLD THEM THE REPRESENTATIONS
MADE BY SOME OF THE STEM CELL.
CLINICS AND AND TOURIST
AMERICANS MAY NOT BE ACCURATE
AND WOULD BE BASICALLY TAKING
YOUR MONEY VERY MUCH LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED DURING THE EARLY CANCER
DAYS IN MEXICO.
WHERE YOU KNOW GOD NOTS FROM
NECTARINES WORTH CONSIDER TO BE?
CURES FOR CANCER WE KNOW THEY
WEREN'T BUT YET A LOT OF PEOPLE
BOUGHT INTO IT.
MORE TO COME ON THAT ISSUE THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU
SIR FOR BEING HERE.
THINK OKAY WE'RE GOING TO
TRANSITION TO OUR NEXT PANEL --
PARTNER PERSPECTIVE.
DOCTOR JAY AND NO ALTERNATE THE
DIRECTOR OF THE UC DAVIS OF STEM
CELL PROGRAM.
AND INSTITUTE.
FOR REGENERATIVE SHEARERS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO OUT WELCOME
DOCTOR NOVA. TO THE PANEL.
THEY BELIEVE WE HAVE A PLATE IS
SO FEW SLIDES.
ARE THEY STILL CALLED SLIDES AND
NOT SURE YEAH AT THAT ABOUT HER
--
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
SO --
HONORED TO BE HERE AND HAVE A
CHANCE TO AT PRESENT TO YOU.
I WANTED TO JUST SHOW YOU A FEW
SLIDES ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS TO US
HERE IN SACRAMENTO UM TO HAVE
SERMON TO HAVE THIS FUNDING AND
TO BE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
WORLD LEADER IN STEM CELL
RESEARCH [inaudible]
SO REALLY.
THE FIELD OF MEDICINE IS
CHANGING WE FEEL IT EVERY DAY AT
THE HOSPITAL --
GENE THERAPIES GENE EDITING
IMMUNOTHERAPY GIVING CANCER
PATIENTS IT A SECOND CHANCE AT
LIFE AND REALLY SPECIALIZED AND
FACILITIES ARE NEEDED FOR THESE
LIVING MEDICINES IS NOT JUST
PILLS IN A BOTTLER.
OF VIOLENCE YOU KNOW ED VACCINE
IT'S LIVING MEDICINES AND SO YOU
NEED THESE REALLY.
VERY SPECIALIZED FACILITIES IN
TEAMS AND TO DO THAT AND THANKS
TO SERVE HIM.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO BUILD THAT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO MANY OTHERS
HAVE BEEN AROUND THE STATE'S
ABLE TO BUILD AND SUCH TEAMS AND
TO DELIVER IT. TO BEGIN TO
DELIVER THESE AT A LIVING
MEDICINE SO WE'VE A VERY.
HONORED TO HAVE THE TEAM
TRAINING THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER --
AND EVERYTHING FROM RESEARCH
THROUGH THE CLINICAL TRIALS
FUNDED BY SIR.
SO THIS IS WHAT OUR PROGRAM LOOK
LIKE IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE A
I CAME BACK HOME HERE TO
SACRAMENTO FRED AFTER SADDAM HAD
SHASTA AND WAS IT A WASHINGTON
UNIVERSITY.
AND WAS CURSED TO COME BACK AND
NOW AND I JUST OVER A DECADE
LATER HERE'S OUR PROGRAM.
SO WE HAVE --
ARE INTER INTER UC DAVIS AND
THEN ALL OF OUR PARTNERS AROUND
THE STATE AND BEYOND AND OUR
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND THANKS
THANKS TO CERTAIN FOR THAT.
OUR BUILDING STARTED OUT AS AN
ALL PART OF THE STATE FAIR.
THE HISTORIC BUILDING THE WHEN I
FIRST CAME BACK IT LOOKED LIKE
THIS IN THE OLD WAREHOUSES AND
NOW IT'S HIGH TECH.
MANUFACTURING FOR STEM CELL
THERAPIES TO SEND TO THE FACE
SINCE.
THE IMPORTANT THING TO KNOW
ABOUT CERTAIN IS THAT THEY FUND
EVERYTHING THROUGH THE BASIC
RESEARCH THE DISCOVERY OF THESE
NOVEL TRIALS.
THROUGH THE PRE CLINICAL
RESEARCH INTO THE CLINICAL
TRIALS.
NIH REALLY DOESN'T FUND THIS
PART IT'S KIND OF BORING TO
THEM.
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH YOU HAVE WDM.
HYPOTHESIS BASED GRANT AND THEN
YOU CAN GET THESE EARLY PHASES
AND THEN THEY WILL FUND SOME --
CLINICAL TRIALS BUT THIS THE
OFTEN CALLED THE VALLEY OF DEATH
IT'S LARGELY LOST WITH THE
FEDERAL FUNDING AND STERN HAS
BEEN ABLE TO TAKE THESE REALLY
PROMISING THERAPIES THROUGH
FROM.
BASIC RESEARCH ALL THE WAY TO
NEED THEM AS YOU WITH THAT BABY
RONNIE EARLIER.
WANTED TO SHOW YOU WHAT IT
ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE TO MAKE
THESE INDUCED PLURIPOTENT STEM
CELLS SO THIS IS BASIC RESEARCH.
AT ITS FINEST YOU START WITH A
LITTLE PINCHING SKIN FIBROBLASTS
FROM THE PATIENT.
WE ADD FACTORS MAKE THEM INTO
THESE INDUCED PLURIPOTENT STEM
CELLS THAT FOR ALL OF THEM.
INTENTS AND PURPOSES REALLY ARE
ALMOST IDENTICAL TO THE
EMBRYONIC STEM CELLS CAN THEN DO
CHARACTERIZATION SEQUENCING --
DIFFERENTIATE THEM SAY INTO
NEURONS STUDY DISEASE IN A DISH
FROM THE INDIVIDUAL PATIENT YOU
HAVE THE GENETICS FROM THAT
INDIVIDUAL PATIENT.
AND THEN WE CAN USE SOMETHING
CALLED CRISPER TO ADD JEAN EDIT
INCORRECT HUMAN NEURONS
TRANSPLANT THEM VERSES AT
CONTROLS AND AVATAR MICE THEY
I WATCH WHAT THEY DO IN THE
BRAIN.
THESE NEURONS FROM THE AND IS
PROPONENTS DON'T STEM CELLS
INTERACT WITH EACH OTHER --
THEY SIGNAL IF THEY HAVE A
DEFECT SUCH AS FROM A AT A CHILD
WITH A NEURO DEVELOPMENTAL
DISORDER WEEKEND TESTED
DIFFERENT DRUGS IN THE DISH AND
SEE HOW WE CAN CORRECT THOSE AS
SIGNALING DEFICITS --
WE HAD THE FIRST --
GROUP THAT MADE VASCULARIZED
BRAIN ORGAN NO AIDS AND SO THE
HUMAN NEURONS CAN SELF ASSEMBLE
INTO THESE MANY BRAINS IN
ADDITION WHICH IS VERY COOL.
WE USE THAT.
TO STUDY DIFFERENT UNDER A
DEGENERATIVE DISEASES SUCH AS
HUNTINGTON'S AND WROTE A
DEVELOPMENTAL DISORDERS AS WELL.
WE'RE VERY LUCKY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO TO HAVE A GOOD
MANUFACTURING PRACTICE FACILITY
THIS WHERE WE ACTUALLY DO THE
CELL AND JEAN MANUFACTURING FOR
THE CLINICAL TRIALS THAT HOW THE
U. S. FDA APPROVALS.
THIS IS.
IN CONTRAST TO THOSE FOR PROFIT
CLINICS THEY DON'T HAVE FTA
APPROVALS --
WE NEED THAT HAVE TO DO THIS IS
ONE OF THE LARGER.
LARGEST ACADEMIC GMP FACILITIES
IN THE USA WE HAVE SIX
INDIVIDUAL SWEETS.
WE WORK WITH MANY ACADEMIC AND
INDUSTRY PARTNERS --
ACADEMIC THROUGH --
GRANTS THAT WE HAVE TOGETHER
THROUGH SERUM AND INDUSTRY IS A
FEE FOR SERVICE SWISS IS GOOD IN
AKRON AMHERST DATA IT'S ACTUALLY
WHAT THEY'RE CALLED GOOD
MANUFACTURING PRACTICE AS
OPPOSED TO BAD MANUFACTURE.
ACT.
AND ARE ARE A DIRECTOR OF
PROFESSOR GERHARD CAN GIVE YOU A
WHOLE LECTURE ON WHY THE BAD
PRACTICES LED TO THE THESE A GMP
IF IF IF IT IS.
I'M NOT GONNA GO INTO THAT IN
INTEREST INTO.
SO THIS OUR PROGRAM RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE TWENTY FOUR A STENCIL
REGENERATE MEDICINE TRIALS ON
GOING OVER TWENTY IN THE
PIPELINE.
THOSE WITH THE GREEN ARROW HAVE
--
FDA APPROVED CLINICAL TRIAL.
AND THE RED ARROWS ARE THOSE
THAT WERE WAITING TO START --
SPEAKING TO THE FDA AT SOME AT
SOME LEVEL PRE PRE AYE INDEED
INVESTIGATIONAL NEW DRUG
APPLICATION OR FURTHER.
WE WERE LUCKY I I SAID THAT
CERTAIN FUNDS ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE PIPELINE CITIES OF
THE BASIC RESEARCH TRANSLATIONAL
IS IN THE AT MEISSEN ANIMAL
MODELS.
AND THEY FUND ALSO THESE
CLINICAL TRIALS WHICH ARE SO SO
IMPORTANT SO WE WERE.
VERY FORTUNATE TO RECENTLY
JOINED THE ALPHA CLINIC NETWORK
--
THESE ARE PROVIDING RELIABLE
CLINICAL TRIALS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
ALSO AND WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT THE
PUBLIC WE GET CALLS EVERY SINGLE
DAY FROM PEOPLE WONDERING ABOUT
TRIALS WONDERING WHERE YOU CAN
THEY GO FOR SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
TRIALS.
AND OUR TEAM WILL GUIDE THEM TO
THE PROPER CLINICAL TRIAL
THROUGH THE CERTAIN NETWORKS
LIST.
AND SO VERY --
GLAD TO BE ABLE --
TO GET THAT HERE IS THE GROUP OF
THE TOP TIER OF MEDICAL CENTERS
WHERE THE WHERE THE ALPHA
CLINICS ARE.
AND REALLY SPECIALIZING IN THIS
OF THESE TYPES OF STEM CELL
THERAPIES THE FIRST ONE WAS --
THE HOPE TRIAL THAT WE DID IT IN
OUR ALPHA CLINIC WHEN IT OPENED
IN THEM SACRAMENTO.
THE HOPE TRIAL FOR OF BOYS THEY
ADDITION MUSCULAR DYSTROPHY AND
WE'VE NOW --
TREATED SEVERAL OF THOSE
PATIENTS AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
CLINICAL TRIALS ON GOING IN OUR
CENTER AND THE HEALTH CLINICS
ARE INTERESTING BECAUSE WHAT WE
HAVE IS AN OUTPATIENT CLINIC TO
COME IN.
AND ACTUALLY GET YOUR STEM
CELERY GENERAL MEDICINE.
AND SO IT'S IT'S REALLY THAT THE
NEXT WAVE OF THERAPY.
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
AT THIRTY THREE COUNTY CATCHMENT
REGION AND SO THESE PATIENTS ARE
ABLE TO COME A INTO A CLINIC CAN
BE TREATED IF.
THE TRIAL WAS APPROVED SO
FINALLY THIS IS REALLY A NEW ERA
OF LIVING MEDICINE --
SELLING GENE THERAPIES FOR
DISEASES AND INJURIES THAT
REALLY DON'T HAVE GOOD.
HERE IS NOW AND WE'RE COMMITTED
TO TRAINING THE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS OF THE FUTURE WORKING
WITH -- THE
IT STUDENTS OF AT ALL LEVELS WHO
ARE LEARNING THESE TECHNIQUES
AND SYSTEM REALLY THRILLED TO BE
BACK AT UC DAVIS BACK HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
AND THAT'S WHEN I WELL THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT THAT.
YOU WERE MENTIONING THAT YOU
WERE DRAWN BACK TO YOU
CALIFORNIA BE BECOME LARGELY
BECAUSE OF PROP.
SEVENTY ONE HA HOW UNIQUE IS
YOUR STORY OR DO YOU SEE A WHOLE
SERVE TALENT BASE.
THAT HAS BEEN DRAWN HERE OR IS
GROWING UP HERE.
ARE A ORGANICALLY --
I MEAN HOW HOW HOW UNIQUE IS
YOUR STORY.
MY STORY IS NOT THAT UNIQUE --
WE IS CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A A
BIG BRAIN DRAIN FOR REALLY
TALENTED PEOPLE IN THIS FIELD
AND IF YOU WANNA IF YOU WANNA DO
STEM CELLS THAT THIS THIS IS
WHERE YOU SHOULD COME.
SO REALLY --
AT A HUGE DRAW IT THANKS TO SIR.
SO AND THEN THE YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE VALLEY OF DEATH AND HOW
CRUCIAL THAT BOND FUNDING HAS
BEEN IN THAT PARTICULAR A PIECE
OF THE PROCESS DO YOU.
I ANTICIPATE GOING FORWARD IF
IF.
FUNDING SOURCE WERE TO BE FOUND
--
RAP --
RENEWED IN TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
DO YOU ANTICIPATE THAT THAT
WOULD CONTINUE TO FILL THAT NEED
--
OR IS THE PROCESS KIND OF MOVING
SO QUICKLY THAT OF BEYOND THAT
THAT THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE NEED
GOING FORWARD OR IS THAT DO YOU
SEE THIS BOND FUNDING CONTINUING
TO SERVE A PURPOSE I GUESS THAT
SERVICE HUGE PURPOSE --
IT'S REALLY CRITICAL TO KEEP THE
MOMENTUM.
GOING IN TO KEEP THE THE FUNDED
--
NETWORK OF CLINICAL TRIALS GOING
AND THE PIPELINE LEADING INTO
THOSE CLINICAL TRIALS I THINK --
THE WORLD IS LOOKING TO US TO
DEVELOP THESE THERAPIES.
AND ESPECIALLY FOR CALIFORNIANS
--
WE HAVE THIS TERM AS SCIENTIST
AT A CERTAIN TO GET THEM IF
CERTAIN ENDS.
THE SO.
WE WE WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK TO
COMPETING FOR THE YOU KNOW THE
NIH FUNDING AND ONLY IN A 528%
OF THE GRANTS THAT YOU PUT AN
END TO THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES
OF HEALTH WILL GET FUNDED.
AND REALLY.
THINGS LIKE SCALING UP FROM A
FEW FLASKS TO IF YOU LEADERS OF
PRODUCT THAT'S NOT OF INTEREST
TO THE TO THE STUDY SECTIONS
THAT REVIEW THE GRANTS FOR THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF HEALTH
PLAN.
CERTAIN HAS BEEN FUNDING THINGS
LIKE THAT --
TECH TRANSFER OF THE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN ACADEMIA
AND INDUSTRY AND REALLY HUGE FOR
SOONER BECAUSE I GET DANIEL IT
MIGHT BE ABLE TO GET GRANTS TO
FUND LIKE IT CLICK OF PHASE ONE
MAYBE FACE TO CLINICAL TRIAL BUT
TO GO.
FORWARD INTERFACE THREE AND THEN
TO GET IT ULTIMATELY APPROVED
FOR REIMBURSEMENT BY INSURANCE
THAT TAKES INDUSTRY PARTNERS AND
THIS IS REALLY WHERE IT'S
HAPPENING IS HEARING CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU DOCTRINAL TO JUST
WANNA SEE OF MY COLLEGE WHO
WE'VE BEEN JOINED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARC LEVINE FROM.
MARIN COUNTY --
TO SOLICIT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR DOCTOR
KNOWLTON SEEING NINE HEARING
NONE.
THANKS VERY MUCH DOCTOR MONEY
SHE HAD A VERY MUCH SO MOVING TO
OUR FINAL [inaudible]
PRESENTER.
WE'LL BE HEARING FROM DAVE
JOHNSON WHO IS THE AUTHOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STEM CELL REPORT
WHICH IS THE ONLY NON
GOVERNMENTAL WEBSITE DEVOTED
SOLELY. TO CALIFORNIA STEM CELL
AGENCY.
MISTER JOHNSON HAS FILED THE
AGENCY SINCE JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND FIVE AS PUBLISHED MORE
THAN FORTY SIX HUNDRED ITEMS IN
THE STEM CELL REPORT.
THE SITE PROVIDES NEWS AND
COMMENTARY ON PUBLIC POLICY
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC ISSUES.
CONCERNING SIR ARM AND JOHNSON
WE WELCOME YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M VERY
PLEASED TO BE HERE.
AND ON THE AND HEAR YOUR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS I THINK
THE AGENCY IS TREMENDOUSLY
IMPORTANT HAS HAD A MAJOR
IMPACT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'D LIKE
TO MENTION HERE IS --
DOCTRINAL TO MENTIONED ABOVE TO
YOU HOPE LUCKY UC DAVIS WAS.
IN FACT THE LOCK IS AND FAR
FROM.
THE SPENT THE OF THE HEAD PEOPLE
AT THE BOARD MEETINGS AT THE ALL
INVOLVED IN THE SERMON ON A
AGENCY.
REGULATE AND THEY WATCHED WHERE
THE DOLLARS ARE GOING WHAT WAS
POSSIBLE AND THEY WENT OUT AND
GOT IT.
BUT IT UC DAVIS IS A GOOD OF
SOME OF THE INTENTIONS BEHIND.
THE HOME OF PROPOSITION SEVENTY
ONE IS TO BUILD UP THE STENCIL
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA --
PUT UP I WAS IN MAZATLAN MEXICO
THE FALL TWO THOUSAND FOUR WHEN
I FIRST HEARD ABOUT THE
PROPOSITION SEVENTY ONE BEING
PASSED.
I READ A HEN A HEADLINE WALL
STREET JOURNAL THAT SAID.
THERE WAS A NEW GOLD RUSH COMING
TO CALIFORNIA.
AND WAS ONE INVOLVING STEM CELLS
INSTEAD OF NUGGETS.
HOLY ARGONAUTS I SAID TO MYSELF
USING THE TERM OF COURSE IT
REFERS TO THE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE RUSHED THE CALIFORNIA
GOLDFIELDS IN.
EIGHTEEN FORTY NINE I WANTED TO
KNOW MORE ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
WITH HIS NEW STEM CELL GOLD
RUSH.
TODAY NEARLY FOURTEEN YEARS
LATER.
I STILL WANT TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
REGENERATIVE MEDICINE.
AS HE AGENCIES FORMERLY KNOWN.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT CERTAIN
FACTS ARE CLEAR.
THE AGENCY IS UNIQUE IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY AND AMONG
STATES THROUGHOUT THE NATION.
THERE'S A FOR STATE AGENCY TO
FUND SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH WITH
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ALL OF IT
PARK.
AND ONE POINTED IT ITS HISTORY
IS SAFE TO SAY AS OTHERS HAVE
REMARKED THAT THE AGENCY IS IS
WHAT WAS.
THE LARGEST SINGLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING IN THE WORLD FOR HUMAN
EMBRYONIC STEM CELL RESEARCH.
THE AGENCY ALSO OPERATES WITH
FINANCIAL OVERSIGHT AUTONOMY
THAT IS RARE IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT.
COURTESY OF THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE.
BUT THAT MEASURE ALSO PROVED TO
BE BOTH A BLESSING AND A CURSE.
THE AGENCY'S FINANCIAL AUTONOMY
IS ALLOWED TO PROVIDE A
REASONABLY STEADY STREAM OF CASH
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS.
SOMETHING IS NECESSARY TO
SUSTAIN THE LONG TERM RESEARCH.
BUT IT'S CRITICAL FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF WIDELY AVAILABLE
TREATMENTS.
AT THE SAME TIME.
THE BALLOT MAJOR CARRIED THE
AGENCIES THAT.
FOR NO MORE MONEY AFTER THE
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IS GONE.
CASH FOR NEW AWARDS AS HASN'T
HARASSMENT PREVENTION IS NOT
EXPECTED TO RUN OUT.
AT THE END OF NEXT YEAR ALL THE
AGENCY COULD SLOW DOWN THE PACE
OF ITS AWARDS AND STRETCH AND A
LITTLE BIT LONGER.
THERE IS AN EFFORT UNDER WAY NOW
TO PRIVATELY RAISE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. TO BRIDGE THE
GAP BETWEEN.
OF THE END OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY OVER IT'S LIFE THE AGENCY
HAS HAVE A NATIONAL AND SOMEWHAT
MORE MODESTLY GLOBAL IMPACT.
BOTH AS A SOURCE OF FUNDING.
AND INTERNATIONAL COOPERATION
BUT ALSO IN STAYING THE COURSE
ON HUMAN EMBRYONIC STEM CELL
RESEARCH ONE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS BACKING AWAY.
BEYOND THAT THE STENCIL AGENCY
IS THE ONLY STATE DEPARTMENT
WHOSE PRIMARY OBJECTIVE IS TO
PRODUCE A MARKETABLE COMMERCIAL
PRODUCT.
IN THIS CASE SECURE OR TREATMENT
FOR AFFLICTIONS NOW NEARLY
UNTREATABLE --
FINALLY AND ALL BUT CERTAIN BUT
CERTAIN IS THE ONLY STATE
AGENCIES BUT TAKES BACK MONEY
WHEN THE PROJECT WILL HEADS UP
ON THE ROCKS.
BY THE END OF LAST MONTH THAT
FIGURE TOTALED IN RECENT YEARS
MORE THAN THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWO BIG CATEGORIES OF
AWARDS.
THAT SORT OF OF CASH RECOVERY IS
NOT A PRACTICE OF OCCURS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
CONCERNED THE MONEY GOES BACK
INTO THE POT. FOR MORE RESEARCH
AIMED AT TREATING ALL THESE
HORRIBLE AFFLICTIONS.
HOWEVER THE AGENCY HAS HIT SOME
SHOALS FROM TIME TO TIME.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN THE
AGENCY'S GOVERNING BOARD
COMMISSION OF SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR STUDY OF ITS
EFFORTS BY THE PRESTIGIOUS
INSTITUTE OF MEDICINE. TWO YEARS
LATER THE IOM WHICH IS SORT OF
PROVISION FOR INSTANT MEDICINE
REPORTED DISCERNMENT HAD SOME
SIGNIFICANT FLAWS.
THE IOM STUDY SAID THAT THE
AGENCY HAD ACHIEVED QUOTE MANY
NOTABLE RESULTS.
BUT IT ALSO RECOMMENDED SWEEPING
CHANGES TO REMOVE CONFLICT OF
INTEREST PROBLEMS CLEAN UP A
TROUBLING DO EXECUTIVE
ARRANGEMENT.
AND FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
NATURE OF THE GOVERNING BOARD.
THE REPORT SAID QUOTE FAR TOO
MANY BOARD MEMBERS REPRESENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT RECEIVE SOME
FUNDING OR BENEFIT FROM THAT
FUND.
THESE COMPETING PERSONAL OR
PROFESSIONAL INTERESTS
COMPROMISE A PERCEIVED
INDEPENDENCE OF THE ICE YOU'LL
SEE WHICH IS A CERTAIN GOVERNING
BOARD.
AND INTRODUCED POTENTIAL BIAS IN
TWO BOARDS DECISION MAKING.
AND THREATEN TO UNDERMINE
CONFIDENCE IN THE BOARD.
BECOME THE CONFLICT ISSUES ARE
BUILT IN TO THE BALLOT
PROPOSITION.
BUT GARY POTENTIAL RECIPIENT
INSTITUTION SEATS ON THE TWENTY
NINE MEMBER BOARD.
AND INDEED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE LAST TIME I
CALCULATED THE CORRELATION
BETWEEN THE BOARD.
AND AWARDS ROUGHLY 90% OF THE
GIVEN OUT PLACER HAS GONE TO
INSTITUTION.
WITH TIES TO MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD.
ABOUT TWO MONTHS AFTER THE OTHER
WHEN PRESENTED ITS REPORT.
THE SERVER BOARD APPROVED A NEW
POLICY BUT CURRENTLY BARGE
THIRTEEN OF ITS TWENTY NINE
MEMBERS FROM VOTING ON ANY
GRANTS WHATSOEVER. TO HELP DEAL
WITH THESE SORTS OF QUESTIONS
CONCERNING CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST.
THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER STUDIES
ABOUT THE AGENCIES OF
PERFORMANCE RESULTING FROM THE
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN LAW.
YOU KNOW IN THAT THE IN THAT
THOUGH ON NEW LAW THE
LEGISLATURE MODIFIED THE
INITIATIVE.
WITH A SUPER DEGREE WHICH
REQUIRES A SUPER MAJORITY VOTE
TO REQUIRE TRIENNIAL PERFORMANCE
AUDITS WOULD BE PAID FOR BY THE
AGENCY ITSELF.
THE REQUIREMENT OVER EXCLUDES
SITE QUOTE SCIENTIFIC
PERFORMANCE FROM THE AUDIT.
THE FIRST AUDIT RESULTS CAME IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AND
CONTAINED TWENTY SEVEN
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVEMENT.
THE MOST RECENT PERFORMANCE
AUDITS CAME LAST SPRING.
THE AUDIT FIRM MOSS ADAMS
RECOMMENDED IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
AREAS OF PRIVATE FUND RAISING
RETENTION OF STAFF AND BETTER
UTILIZATION OF BOARD MEMBERS.
THE BOARD WAS TOLD THAT THE
AGENCY HAD QUOTE MADE INCREDIBLE
PROGRESS.
AND THAT THE AUDITORS USUALLY
SEAT LOTS OF GOOD THINGS.
IN RECENT YEARS THE AGE OF HE
HAS BEEN ON A SELF IMPROVEMENT
REGIME THE EFFORT BEGAN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN WAS DUBBED
CERTAIN TWO POINT.
OH BUT TERM WAS ORIGINALLY
COINED BY WHO STEM CELL
RESEARCHER HERE AT UC DAVIS.
THE NEW DIRECTION AND EMPHASIS
WAS DESCRIBED BY THE AGENCY AS
RADICAL HUSSEIN DID IMPROVING
SPEED EFFICIENCY OF ELEVATION.
AND IT SEEMS TO HAVE LARGELY
SUCCEEDED.
AND TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN IT
TOOK ALMOST TWO YEARS FOR GOOD
IDEA TO GO FROM APPLICATION TO
THE FINAL FUNDING STATE.
THE GOAL WAS TO SHORTEN THAT TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS DELAYS
IN FUNDING OR A PARTICULAR
CONCERN TO BUSINESSES.
AND OFTEN FOR CASUAL REASONS BUT
THEY ALSO MEAN DELAYS AND
ACTUALLY CAN THE HOPE OF A CURE
OR TREATMENT.
INTO THE MARKETPLACE.
THIS WEEK WE AGENCY SAID THE
CASH DELIVERY FIGURE NOW STANDS
AT LESS THAN NINETY DAYS FOR
CLINICAL AWARD.
AND ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS
FOR TRANSLATION TOWARDS.
AND TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE
AGENCY WAS PARTICIPATING IN
ONLINE CLINICAL TRIALS.
A LOT OF STAGE BEFORE TREATMENT
IS CERTIFIED FOR WIDESPREAD USE
TODAY THE AGENCIES INVOLVED IN.
FORTY NINE IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN ABOUT
FIFTY PATIENTS WERE INVOLVED IN
THOSE TRIALS TODAY THE FIGURES
MORE THAN. EIGHT HUNDRED ONE OF
THE MORE INTERESTING ASPECTS OF
SIR POINT CERN TWO POINT OH
MARKED A DEPARTURE FROM WHAT
MIGHT BE CALLED AN ACADEMIC PASS
FAIL APPROACH.
TO PUT FINAL EXAM FOR
APPLICATION FROM INSTRUCTORS.
INSTEAD.
SERVICE ENGAGEMENT MORE PARTNER
ORIENTED APPROACH THAT CAN BE
FOUND IN SOME BUSINESSES.
INSTEAD OF FLATLY FEELING THE
APPLICATION IS NOT QUITE READY
FOR PRIMETIME THE IDEA IS TO TO
COACH THE APPLICANTS ALONG. TO
HELP BRING THEM UP TO THE
APPROVAL LEVEL TODAY THE AGENCY
CAN COUNT THIRTY APPLICATIONS
BUT ONE APPROVAL THROUGH THAT
PROCESS.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S RESEARCH BUT
COULD HAVE SLIPPED AWAY.
IN THE MORE DISTANT PAST.
SAM IS NOW MUCH MORE ENGAGE WITH
INDUSTRY THAN VARIANTS EARLIER
YEARS WHEN IT DREW BETTER
CHRISTIAN CRITICISM FROM SOME
BUSINESS EXECUTIVES.
ENGAGEMENT WITH BIOTECH FIRMS IS
CRITICAL BRINGING TREATMENTS TO
THE PUBLIC.
TERMS NOT IN THE BUSINESS OF
ACTUALLY MANUFACTURING AND
MARKETING AND SELLING PRODUCTS
THAT IS A MATTER LEFT TO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. ONE REASON FOR
CLOSER BUSINESS CONNECTIONS
INVOLVES OF MATURATION OF THE
WORK IN THE FIELD.
WHICH IS BROUGHT RESEARCHER AND
A CLOSER TO REALITY BUT IS ALSO
BLEW UP TO DIFFERENT FOCUS
WITHIN THE AGENCY AS TOP
MANAGEMENT HAS CHANGED. ONE OF
THE MORE DIFFICULT AREAS
INVOLVING STEM CELL RESEARCH
UNLIKELY TREATMENT PESAR COST.
IT IS RARE TO HEAR RESEARCHERS
ARE COMPANIES TALK ABOUT --
FORTHRIGHTLY IN PUBLIC ABOUT
SPECIFIC DOLLAR AMOUNTS.
THE COST OF DRUGS AND TREATMENT
OF OUR HIGH VISIBILITY MATTERS
FOR YOU FOLKS HERE IN WASHINGTON
AND FOR PATIENTS.
ESTIMATES OF OVER YOU SOME OF
THE ESTIMATES FOR STEM CELL
TREATMENTS AND CURRENTLY RUN UP
TO THE AT LEAST NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN THE
LEGISLATURE MOVED TO HELP ASSURE
AFFORDABILITY BE REQUIRED BY
RECORDING GRANTEES TO SUBMIT
AFFORDABLE ACCESS PLANS WITH A
COPY DOT BUT THE AGENCY COULD
WAIVE THAT REQUIREMENT.
HOW THAT WILL ULTIMATELY PLAYOFF
ON AN ACTUAL PRODUCTS?
WHEN WE COME INTO THE
MARKETPLACE IS YET TO BE
DETERMINED?
THEY'RE ALSO SOME POLICY
QUESTIONS THAT ARE IMPORTANT AND
AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
STEM CELL PROGRAM IN THE NEW USE
OF THE PALACE INITIATIVE. ONE IS
ABOUT IS THE BALLOT INITIATIVE
THE BEST WAY TO APPROACH SUCH AS
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH AND CREATE
NEW STATE PROGRAMS.
DOES THE STATE HAVE HIGHER
HEALTH PRIORITIES SUCH AS PRE
NATAL CARE THAN SUPPLYING
RESEARCHERS WITH CASH THAT COULD
WELL SECURE FROM OTHER SOURCES.
THIS GOES TO THE SCREENING
QUESTION THAT GOES.
ON ASSEMBLY WOMAN NOT WALDRON
MATCH.
SHOULD WE PAY FOR THAT INSTEAD
OF SOMETHING FARTHER DOWN THE
ROAD.
IS BORROWING MONEY TO FINANCE
RESEARCH THE BEST WAY TO GO
ABOUT.
THE INTERESTS AND EXPENSE
RAISES%
LIKE TOTAL COST OF A TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR RESEARCH AWARD TO
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
SHOULD EXECUTIVES OF POTENTIAL
RECIPIENT INSTITUTIONS SERVE ON
THE BOARD TOWARDS THEIR
EMPLOYERS HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS A YEAR.
JUST A SHORT LIST BUT THESE ARE
MATTERS THAT WILL COME UP AND
REPEATEDLY ESPECIALLY AS A NEW
INITIATIVE IS OFFERED.
RETURNING TO THE EARLIER LIST OF
CLEAR FACTS ABOUT CERTAIN
ANOTHER FACT IS THAT LIVES HAVE
BEEN SAVED AS WE'VE SEEN SO
DRAMATICALLY HERE THIS MORNING.
AND INSERM REGULARLY --
OF HAS FORUMS FOR THESE SORTS OF
APPEARANCES BUT YET THOSE ARE
ALL CLINICAL TRIALS AND NOT.
ACTUALLY THE TREATMENT IS WIDELY
AVAILABLE.
LITTLE DOUBT EXISTS THAT THE
AGENCY HAS ADVANCED THE STEM
CELL FIELD IN THIS BUILDING
PORTS A CRITICAL MASS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE BURGEONING RESEARCH PROGRAM
AT UC DAVIS HAS HAD NOW HAS
TAKEN IN THE HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN CERTAIN
FUND.
IT VIRTUALLY DIDN'T EXIST IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR ANOTHER IS A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR ALFA CLINIC
PROGRAM.
JIM NOT ONLY INVOLVES THE UC
DAVIS BUT UC SAN FRANCISCO YOU
SEE IT ALL IN.
UC IRVINE.
AND THE CITY OF HOPE ON THE LOS
ANGELES AREA ALL OF OUR PARTLY
OPEN NETWORK.
NONE THE LESS CERTAIN HAS NOT
YET DEVELOPED AYE BUT HER BACK.
STEM CELL TREATMENT BUT IS READY
FOR WIDESPREAD USE.
AND THAT WAS ONE OF THE VOTER
EXPECTATIONS AND AT THE END TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR THE AGENCY HAS
SOMETHING OF A DEADLINE BECAUSE
OF THEM NOVEMBER OF BECAUSE
LITTLE.
AND THE END OF THE FUNDING.
AND THEIR BACKERS ARE HOPING FOR
ANOTHER BALLOT INITIATIVE IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY THAT
WOULD OPEN ADDITIONAL FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE INTO THE
PROGRAM.
AND DEVELOPMENT OF A STEM CELL
THERAPY THERE ARE THREE THOUGH
IT COULD BE A COUPLE OF GREAT
ADDRESS AND MANAGE SHOULDN'T BE
AN ELECTION.
THERE ARE THREE CLINICAL TRIALS
AT THE SERMONS OF BACKING THE
VERNE FACE.
THREE AND THE OF SOME OF THOSE
COULD BLOW OF A RESULT WITH A
HEAT.
THERAPY.
BUT AS FOR NOW WE DON'T KNOW
WHETHER THE STENCIL GOLD RUSH OF
TWO THOUSAND FOUR IT'S GOING TO
MEASURE UP TO THE GOLD RUSH OF
EIGHTEEN FORTY NINE AND THAT.
REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
WELL WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND AND YOUR EXPERTISE
AND HAVING FOLLOWED THE SO
CLOSELY FOR FOR MANY YEARS NOW
SO YOU MENTION THE GOVERNMENT'S
CHALLENGES --
THAT HAVE BEEN CITED IN THE PAST
--
YOU RACIST SERIES OF QUESTIONS
OFFER FOR ALL OF US TO CONSIDER
[inaudible]
SHOULD --
SHOULD A BOND AN ADDITIONAL BOND
PASS AND ANOTHER FUNDING STREAM
BE IDENTIFIED --
THAT'S SORT OF OBVIOUS OBVIOUSLY
THE IMMEDIATE --
CHALLENGE FOR CONTINUING --
MUCH OF THIS WORK.
GOING FORWARD ASSUMING THAT WERE
TO HAPPEN AND THAT'S A BIG
ASSUMPTION BUT ASSUMING THAT
WERE TO HAPPEN --
WHAT DO YOU FORESEE WOULD BE THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE GOING FORWARD
--
IN TERMS OF THAT HAVING A
HIGHER.
HAVING THESE INVESTMENTS COME TO
FRUITION.
OF FOR FOR PATIENTS AND ACTUALLY
OF AFFECTING PEOPLE'S LIVES IN A
POSITIVE WAY.
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE GOING
FORWARD IT WAS PRETTY MUCH OF
YOU KNOWS BOTH THE BUSINESS AND
AND THE SCIENCE QUESTION --
YOU GOT YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
SOME PUSH BACK OF COSTS ARE
GOING TO BE AYE VIDEO AND THE
ADMITTEDLY A LOSE COSTS ARE IT'S
AN EARLY STAGE IN CAN BRING COST
FOUND.
IN THE ARE ALSO ONE TIME
TREATMENTS  YOU KNOW
HEPATITIS C. CONTROVERSIES WHERE
YOU HAVE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF TREATMENT THAT IS SO.
INSECURE OR HAS SOME ISSUES
BECAUSE SO CLOSE.
OF PROBLEMS WITH THE FOOD HE A
PATIENT CENTERED.
IT MINISTER THAT CAN GET RE
INFECTED AND LOTS OF HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS [inaudible]
NOT AFFECT.
SO THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN
WHETHER IT WILL THAT BUT THE THE
INDUSTRY BECAUSE OF THE
REIMBURSEMENT SH.
IT'S IN THE ETSY EUPHEMISM FOR
HOW DO WE MAKE A PROFIT ON THAT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW UNLESS YOU MAKE
A PROFIT THESE THINGS ARE GOING.
TO BE DEVELOPED AND THERE IS
WORK THAT SERVICE DOING
CONCERNING REIMBURSEMENT ISSUES
ARE TALKING TO INDUSTRY AND THE
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS.
HELLO AND HOW THAT OF OTHERS
SOLD DIDN'T GO OVER TO THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES.
SO THAT IT CAN BE REIMBURSED AS
WELL AS THE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
INVOLVED IS IS A BIG QUESTION
YET TO BE RESOLVED.
A LOT OF THE STUFF THE GENE
THERAPIES.
STEM CELL THERAPIES ARE VERY
VERY [inaudible]
OF AND BUT IT'S IT'S THESE GOOD
MANUFACTURING FACILITIES
POWERFUL LIMITED CAPACITY THEY
CAN'T TURN OUT MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF TREATMENTS OF OF AND
AND BRINGING THAT INTO A REAL
MANUFACTURING PROCESS IS ANOTHER
MATTER [inaudible]
THAT QUIRK [inaudible]
ARMED WITH SERVICE SOME EXTENT
--
IF THIS IS GOING TO GO ON THE
BALLOT.
QUESTION THE IS.
NOT ONE THAT WE WILL NECESSARILY
ADDRESS HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE
THINK ABOUT IN A GENERAL CONTEXT
--
YOU SAID YOU KNOW IS THIS
PARTICULAR APPROACH THE ONE THAT
WE WANT.
TO S. SPEND OUR TIME ON A SHOULD
WE INSTEAD BE LOOKING AT GENE
THERAPY THROUGH CRISPER AND
FINDING THAT.
OR FINDING --
RESEARCH AND GLOBAL WARMING.
WHICH IS THE ONE THING I THINK
BESIDES NUCLEAR WAR THE COULD
DESTROY CIVILIZATION.
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF PRIORITIES
FURTHER.
WHEN YOU HAVE A BOND COSTS GOING
FOR YEARS THE COST OF THE FIRST
BOND?
WE WERE PAIN WHEN WE WERE
CUTTING SCHOOLS CUTTING.
ARE A TO Z. --
DISABLED IT CETERA.
AND IF THERE'S A NEW FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR BOND IT'LL BE
MONEY COMING OUT OF THE GENERAL
FUND PEOPLE.
OFTEN DON'T PUT TWO AND TWO
TOGETHER.
AND THINK REALIZE IT COMES OUT
OF THE GENERAL FUND BUDGET DOES.
AND WILL WE HAVE OUR NEXT
RECESSION WHICH WE PROBABLY WELL
WITHIN THE NEXT DECADE.
WITH PAIN FOR BOTH THOSE BONDS
IT IS SOMETHING THAT THE PEOPLE
OF THE STATE REALLY NEED TO
THINK ABOUT I DON'T KNOW THAT.
THROUGH THE ELECTORAL PROCESS
YOU REALLY GOING TO GET THAT --
TRICKED THE THOUGHTS OF THE
VOTERS TRADING OFF WELL SHOULD
BE THIS SHOULD IT BE THAT.
SHOULD BE RESEARCH INTO LA --
HOW TO PREVENT GLOBAL WAR MEAN
IN DEVELOPING OF TECHNOLOGIES
THERE BECAUSE I CAN ASSURE YOU
THERE IS A VALLEY OF DEATH? FOR
NEW TECHNOLOGIES TO CREATE
BIOFUELS [inaudible]
AT CETERA SO IT REALLY IS A
QUESTION OF PRIORITIES AND I
HOPE THE VOTERS A LOOK AT THAT
THANK YOU.
AND THE QUESTIONS.
SEEING HEARING NONE THANK YOU
SIR VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE WE
ARE UP ACTUALLY PASSED OUR THREE
PM -- TIME --
I WANT TO SAVE LIMITS BUT IT'S
NOT REALLY A LIMIT BECAUSE WE DO
YOU WANT TO OFFER PUBLIC COMMENT
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO COME FORWARD
AND ADDRESS.
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY [inaudible]
ANY TAKERS MAYBE NOT.
SO SEEING NO ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
OUR SPEAKERS ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS MY COLLEAGUES.
FOR A SPENDING SOMETIME WITH US
TODAY --
THIS WILL CONCLUDE THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ABOUT TECHNOLOGIES
HEARING ON THE SERMON AND MORE
TO COME ON ALL OF THESE ISSUES
SO THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH WE
ARE ADJOURNED